when you point the finger we know we're
live
not that finger come on
paul hey hey this is samuel i tell you
one time are you gonna do it turn off
your awesome okay officially we
are live we are live
so 43 by the way you missed it if you
were listening to us 30 seconds ago
the team thinks we should get a egg
white sponsorship for the podcast
because i have my egg whites
every morning and wine and wine danielle
would love that and one of these days on
the podcast we should do the podcast
with a glass of wine and see how that
goes
maybe it'll be more entertaining second
half of it what you don't know is i get
drunk every time before
we have the great danielle di martino
booth
here with us in boca raton and we have
adam sosnick today adam look at the
camera and show off your glasses please
let them see that
that good look superman aka adam sauce i
i guess how smart he is
i have to like step up my iq to even sit
next to danielle so i had to wear my
glasses
i forgot my pocket protector but i did
bring the visine
here at the mouth of the rats yes that's
boca raton yeah so
originally originally it was plural
danielle
something tells me you want to bust out
your venezuelan spanish accent while
you're here in south florida
danielle's feeling the vibe she's giving
the bestos to the people by the way
i wish i wish there was an element of
a a camera on to see our conversation
yesterday for the podcast prep
because that was real podcast
that's what i'm hoping danielle brings
today she might have dropped uh
she was raised on a trading floor and
she speaks like it she's like a sailor
whoa where'd that come from so we got a
lot of good topics today we're going to
find
out what uh uh danielle's thoughts are
on the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
stimulus package
and we'll talk about with all the pump
of money into the economy what's going
to happen obviously this last week we
found out about the wealth tax elizabeth
warren's going around saying if you
have more than 50 million dollars every
penny above a million 50 million you're
going to pay 2 cents and then above a
billion it's 5
cents and specs are now a 700 billion
dollar market lift
jumps as company marks best week for
ride since the start of the pandemic
tesla to launch full self-driving car
with subscription within four months
that's pretty crazy to say
within four months and but they better
hurry because everybody else is
doing their business everybody else is
doing it everybody's doing electric
vehicles okay
but but self-driving electric vehicles i
mean you're sitting like i would need a
next level
that is not a bad idea for a guy like me
i said the best idea
for someone like me yeah so then by the
way we should probably switch
you should drive cars i should probably
not drive cars and take ubers
because you actually drive sloan you're
very responsible and safe yes you don't
have to you can you can text and drive
and do your zooms
i've never seen somebody text drive zoom
conference calls
allegedly that's my just speculation
that's a lot of speculation don't drive
on the sidewalks
that's dangerous google to stop selling
targeted ads based on browsing history
so those cookies those cookies may be
going away
lvmh market cap 320 billion
becoming the highest valued company in
the european stock stimulus dollars are
going taxpayers you think so
to louie so they're killing it governor
abbott did something that daniel de
martino may not agree with which we're
going to have a nice banter here
about that opening up fully a hundred
percent and says
no more mandating masks to the point
where 50 cent is thinking about leaving
california
to a different place because he lives in
california new york it's
in new york too uh because he's not
happy about it somebody says
premature emasculation there you go
okay so we'll we'll touch up on that
target toyota gmac
macy's and texas are going to keep
wearing masks texas isn't the only state
lifting cover 19 restrictions there's
other 11 states which will cover that as
well mississippi
yes mississippi was on our list as well
brazil's oil industry shake up could be
devastating for its economy i know you
got some things to say about that
california is poised
for 19 billion despite cover 19 lockdown
second former aide
accuses governor cuomo of sexual
harassment by the way i don't know if
you saw him yesterday on tv
how he responded to that was pretty
interesting chris cuomo criticized for
hypocrisy
after he says he won't cover brothers
controversy i have some
some thoughts on that and elizabeth
warren rips stock buybacks as
nothing but paper manipulation and in
couple pop culture
dr seuss six books have been canceled
you got to get them off they're not
selling them yesterday the top eight
selling books on amazon were all
dr seuss eight for eight you bought how
many i bought 100 or eight no i bought
eight four eight
to support dr seuss wow so then we have
barack obama and
bruce springsteen team up for new
podcasts which i believe will blow up so
having said that
let's get into the stimulus let's get
into the stimulus and the reason why i
want to get into the stimulus because of
a conversation i had with a realtor
yesterday
okay so first let me read off what we
have obviously american rescue plan
biden's 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus
package
the 1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package
includes direct stimulus payments of
per person extending unemployment
compensation raising the minimum wage
continuing eviction and foreclosure
moratoriums and increasing the child tax
credit while making it refundable
it provides funds for the state and
local governments to help compensate for
lost tax revenue money for schools
from kindergartens through eighth grade
to safely open reopen amidst the
pandemic etc etc etc so
1.9 trillion dollars that's four
trillion in the last two years
right now in the last 12 months oh 6.1
when you add it all up
when you add it off post covet yeah some
are saying
where are we getting the 6 trillion
because i know the the cares act was 2
trillion
this is potentially another 2 trillion
906 billion
that was what january that was uh
before trump last left office so that's
almost five trillion
well and then there was other you know
expenditures still taking place so say
five to six trillion dollars okay yeah
no i'm not questioning it i'm just like
we're trying to
see where all these numbers are this is
this is all of it pissed into the wind
by the way none of it productive daniel
i saw an article saying the fact that
uh 20 to 40 percent of the currency ever
printed in the history of america was
printed in the last 20 20
12 months just like that just like that
and we just assume that the dollar is
going to maintain its hegemony that it's
going to
maintain its reserve currency status we
take it for granted because we've had it
for 100 years
so what's going to happen because i hear
two different schools of thought and let
me kind of give you both of them let me
give you both of them
one is you know you got these you know
p ratios that are just ridiculous 1250
tesla okay
uh you got these shoulder p ratios today
that are indicating that you know
market's going to be facing
99th percentile that's pretty scary to
be there
you got interest rates went up a little
bit which is good to see that taking
place a little bit went up and
you and i were kind of going seeing if
you want if you don't want it
but a guy is sitting the real estate guy
i'm talking to this guy
he is the seller's real estate agent
obviously he's not representing me and
it is a seller's market it is a seller's
market today in florida and it's
ridiculous
so he says let me tell you why i need to
buy this house and why this value this
land is going to double in the next
three to five years i said tell me why
he says because that 1.9 trillion
dollars they put into the economy that's
four trillion dollars last 12 months he
says
inflation's going to the roof and the
value of things that cannot be
duplicated is
going to go to the roof such as land
okay so he's not selling structure
hard assets he's saying land so you know
we talked about land gold baseball cards
all this other stuff that's going to art
to the roof
is this gonna make the economy and dow
go to 40 50 60 000 or is this eventually
going to get america
because it seems like we're on a run
rate i know this whole thing about 128
months that we had economic expansion
kova disrupted it we're back at it again
so if you take covert out it could have
been 140 month economic expansion that
we have
what is going to happen with all this
money we're printing a we were going
into recession
anyways in 2020 the federal reserve
needed an excuse to print money
you've never had a year where you have
global trade
world trade contract for a 12 month
solid without the econ the global
economy going into recession
that was 2019. we were headed there
anyways the fed needed an excuse to bail
out the bond market and it got it with
covet it needed a black swan event and
it got it
so that's the one thing that people need
to understand is this was not
the slowdown that we had was not
catalyzed by covet
it wasn't covet was needed for the fed
to come in
with their printing press and the fed
got it they needed the excuse
there was all this repo madness go go
back and look at the end of 2019
when the fed was doing not qe because
there were issues with
overnight lending in america i mean this
is all in
the weeds and wonky but it was happening
that there was real disruption in the
in the overnight markets and the fed
needed an excuse to start pumping
huge amounts of money into the economy
and it got it
it got it with covet and that's why we
are where we are today
because of the printing press but you
cannot
have sustained inflation with 19 million
americans collecting unemployment
benefits you can't
you can have a massive inflation scare
and that's going to benefit your
your real estate not your real estate
agent but the seller's real estate
that's going to benefit them because
it's a great narrative it's fantastic
but it won't be sustained not until you
get these people to work
okay so so what does that mean though it
won't be sustained okay let's get him
back to work people eventually go back
to work you remember when barack obama
said unemployment benefits six months no
12 months no 24 months well this this
new stimulus package pushes it out to
september
sure but eventually people are going to
go back to work they're going to have to
go back to work i know three and a half
million people you're saying
fully lost like permanent permanent job
losses right 300 at recessionary levels
okay but but what i'm saying to you is
like
look if you and i go out there and keep
raising debt
okay we keep getting credit cards and we
get more credit cards
and more credit that's what america is
doing we've been doing it
for years yeah but but at this level but
how come a massive
ridiculous crash hasn't yet hit
what is the key indicator for that to be
taking place there's no
replacement for the dollar the euro is a
joke
italy is a mess they never after we had
the global financial crisis in 2008 2009
our banks were forced to clean up their
balance sheets get rid of the bad debts
that didn't happen in europe japan's
sorry goodbye so there's no replacement
for the dollar
until china gets to be bigger and
because of covid and how
we've approached stimulus spending
versus how china has approached stimulus
spending
it was going to be 2030 that china was
the largest economy in the in the world
now it's 2028. if their currency
continues to appreciate versus the
dollar it'll be 2026
five years from now that china is the
bigger economy and then
we'll have a separate discussion about
what's going to replace the dollar and
then your real estate agent
seller guy he's going to be right then
okay my timeline is 20 25 what's your
timeline
for china no no my timeline for the
market to have a
massive collapse like we're going to
feel the pain i have 20 25. what are you
thinking
once the recognition is out there that
we're not
going to be the global economic
superpower it's game over
that's going to take a few years to
happen unpack game over yeah what does
it mean game over
well we benefit because we can
borrow at such low cost because we're
the we're the we're the global reserve
currency
so you have all of the
liberals in congress saying there's it
is a free lunch
we can borrow as much as we want 1.9
trillion today
we can have five trillion seven trillion
dollar deficits every year
there's never going to be consequences
for the
amount of debt we're taking on and that
works until it stops working
but you have people like janet yellen
and jerome powell who i wouldn't
so like i know you have strong feelings
on that j and j so
but they're championing of course they
are
uh all this uh 40 years of falling
interest rates it's all they seem to
think can possibly happen
but they're not studying history they're
not studying the fact that
that great britain lost the pound as
british pound sterling lost its reserve
currency status because
great britain took on too much debt so
if if you start to think that the rules
don't apply
after 100 years or so and that's it's
been a hundred years
let me follow up with that speaking of
studying history so
we're familiar what happened a hundred
years ago
world war one uh spanish flu yeah
roaring 20s rocking and rolling
prohibition
people are sneaking drinks you know boom
1929 i think it was october
was um it's the start of the great
depression
right which lasted all the way to the
1930s so speaking of history and history
repeating itself you're you're
predicting 1928 potentially
1925 potentially 25 20 20. i'm sorry
2028 are we essentially saying that
that's
potentially what we're in line for is
another
great depression worse than certainly
coveted or not so sure that we have a
whole decade in front of us
this is not a repeat of the roaring 20s
if you look back at the price to
earnings ratio in
december of 1920 it was 4.8
this is i'm going to make this really
simple yeah it was 4.8 in december
of 1920 100 years later in december of
it was seven times that level say that
one more time say that one more time
stocks were seven times more expensive
coming into 2021 than they were going
into 1921.
seven times more expensive so you can't
convince me that we're at the precipice
of
a roaring decade for the for the u.s
economy
what do you mean stocks are seven times
more expensive the price to earnings
ratio the cape
schiller that looks back over was 4.8
times earnings in december 1920.
it was seven times that level in
december of the year 2020. yeah yeah
that make that's that's a concern so
so here's so for me i trust math
more than i trust enthusiasts well then
you trust what i just said seven times
more expensive that's exactly where i'm
at i'm at the math side i lean i trust
matt
right when it comes down to things like
this math is going to tell you what the
future is going to look like you just
have to look at the right math right
but but the part i think about is the
following so you know when
world war one when germany had the debt
that they had to pay off with the
reparations they what they they're like
dude we don't have this kind of money to
pass it they went quietly behind closed
doors and what did they do
they started printing money printing
money paying money to pay off the debt
they paid it up but hyperinflation took
germany to crazy levels and then
boom they took him a while to recover
from it
why are so many brilliant minds in
finance
so optimistic about the direction the
economy is going why are they so
optimistic
you gotta talk your book you're saying
they're trying to sell a book or is that
oh yeah your book of business you you
have to i mean it's their jobs
to pump up the market it's their jobs to
keep people invested in the stock market
it's their jobs to say
for the long haul you're always getting
you're always going to get paid off
what's what's your
level of trust for jerome powell
and or janet yellen your level of trust
10 out of 10 is
they're the best i love them one is i
wouldn't trust them all right so i'm
going to send you a copy of a book
called fed up
okay what you wrote i know i'm familiar
with it it's got janet's words in it
okay okay what are you saying what is it
for the people that haven't read the
book she's a
uc berkeley educated labor economist
who's in charge of the biggest economy
in the world
who doesn't understand the financial
system like she should
and she is in a place
where she can finally lay the groundwork
to to policy in the united states
not benefiting the top one percent but
benefiting
everybody which will ignite inflation
like you've never seen
it's that's a bad thing it's the idea of
helicopter money it's the idea of
getting money
directly to the people as opposed to
saying there'll be a trickle-down effect
if we make lending easier if we make
borrowing costs
lower then companies are going to borrow
and spend and hire
that isn't has not worked instead they
bought back their shares
and 42 billion you've seen the
financialization of america which is
non-productive
it does not create jobs so janet yellen
is is bitter
that she was at the head of the fed
when this wealth effect when wealth
inequality was widening
if she has the power now to reopen the
federal reserve act of 1913
to allow for direct deposits to the
people
there's no wall street in between
there's no intermediary you're going to
get money directly to the people
and you want inflation you'll get
inflation then so
by the way it was 25 billion that
berkshire hathaway bought back of their
shares but
because there's nothing to buy it it's
your map it's too expensive yeah
well it's also banking on yourself like
you know you know
you know where the value is yeah you
know where the value is yeah i i don't
know
to me uh i and that was the most so
disappointing letter warren buffett i
mean he's 90 i get it but
he didn't he didn't take a stand on
anything controversial
it was a wanton seriously america is the
best bet on american
american or fixed income is this you're
coming out of the most controversial
presidential election your murder rate's
going through the roof
the the the the country's clearly in a
crisis mode
and you say nothing about what
the ills of the country when you have
what would you expect them to say like
what would you want to hear from them
a generation ago he said that share
buybacks were
weapons of mass destruction excuse me
derivatives were weapons of mass
destruction and he derided sheer
buybacks
in his prior life because he was like if
if you've got a bunch of people's money
and you can't put it to work
and and make investments and grow their
money then what are you what are you
doing in business that was his attitude
about share buybacks
years ago and he took a stand in saying
that derivatives were
weapons of mass destruction he didn't
say anything that was like
wow controversial nothing he was like
apple's great
well no [ __ ] sorry i mean we all have it
right apple
but he didn't it was very disappointing
what about um
elizabeth warren and hers well no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
let's stay on this stuff
i don't want i don't want to get away
from this because this to me you know
when we're talking
uh uh economy and maths so you're saying
you're gonna get what you're gonna get
which is inflation like you you just you
just said that before we went
but you have to have a crisis you can't
just willy-nilly reopen the federal
reserve act
you have to have something happen to
where
there's namura big bank out of japan
said that every 20 cents of the dollar
that's printed of stimulus
goes into the economy in other words 80
doesn't there's they were saying that
the multiplier effect of stimulus
spending
is crashing we know that 53 of the last
stimulus bill was
saved so what good does it do to spend
all of this money if it's not being
injected into the economy
if it's not creating jobs and that i
think is where the democrats are
really really missing the message
because they say they want to do
infrastructure spending
they say that there's another bill
coming but they're ramming this all
through with reconciliation there's not
a single person in the gop
much to say nothing of moderate
democrats who are on board with what
they're doing
so they're going to burn every damn
bridge before they get to
true stimulus spending that creates jobs
i mean you could fall into a damn
pothole in new york city if you're in a
small car
and be lost forever there's bridges that
are collapsing
and you've got high-speed railways in
china that go zillions of miles an hour
and they're in the middle of
constructing 30 airports and getting
ready to eat the united states as lunch
and we can't even pass
fiscal spending that creates jobs and
repairs our infrastructure i mean fdr
wrote the book
i'm no huge fdr fan but it was a
public-private partnership
and it created generations plural of
productivity
and job creation and we're giving people
money to not work
whoa hashtag winning at a seven percent
unemployment though at a seven percent
unemployment
we're not talking about that eleven
percent ten percent that's seven percent
unemployment we've had seven percent
many many different times we have and
it's not a bad level and it's 6.3
and that's all good and well but that's
because so many people have left the
workforce
so that's your math if you've got people
who've given up that's why you have
a 6.3 unemployment rate but still 19
million americans collecting
unemployment benefits and that's why
you've got this stimulus spending is
just to kind of cr
we're going to have the best economic
growth in america in 2021 since 1983.
it'll be five six percent gdp we're
going to have a blockbuster year that's
what they've been projecting
six percent you can't jam two trillion
dollars into the economy and not expect
gdp to grow it's gonna grow okay so then
it's not going to create
jobs so you're going to come out at the
other end of it going oh god we we need
more stimulus spending
and more yet and more yet and so you're
going to get the stephanie
kelton's of the world so you don't think
this 1.9 is the last 1.9 we're doing the
next two three years
no so you think there's more 1.9
coming up at least a trillion dollar
infrastructure bill right
a trillion no no no i'm talking about a
trillion doesn't even address
i mean look there's there's there's two
three trillion dollars just to do the
repairs
modernization i'm talking about repairs
and then potential green energy bill
right oh god help me well let's not
let's
let's still stay on this because here's
here's my thought so
dow's right now at what the 30 what 31
okay so let's say it's at 31.
if it's gonna be a six percent gdp
and if if you don't think things are
going to turn around in the next you
know
three four years say 2025 2026 when
china
whose plan they came up with made in
2025 made in china 2025 their plan was
to be the number one superpower by 2025.
they're on track to be that by 2025 2026
you know where do you see dow going the
next 12 24 months do you see it going to
40 50 60
you know i'm that that i don't do
do are you optimistic it's going to be
going i think that looks like the way
it's going it's going to go higher i
think we have a correction in front of
us that we're in the midst of right now
and between the
money printing that we have to come the
liquidity that's going to be injected in
the economy you could certainly see a
correction
and then another run-up another melt-up
i
i see i don't see this slowing down the
next couple years
you don't see this happening but that's
just liquidity you're just talking about
you're just you can't have a drought if
it doesn't stop raining
and the fed's going to keep printing
money as long as we have license to do
so because we have king
dollar which has been weaponized it's
actually a great analogy
can't have a drought if it keeps raining
they're making it rain they're making it
rain they're pretty straight up they're
you know they're getting dirty
making it rain you've got janet yellen
in the house i mean the the
the rain maker dj janet yeah
making it rain even worse i mean she
would
when she was the chair of the fed and
she would go in front of congress and do
her testimony and they would ask her
about financial regulation
her eyeballs would roll into the back of
her head she was so bored
i'm sorry but steve mnuchin was a master
at what he did
hmm and he's an ammunition fan i'm not
i'm not saying i'm a neutron fan i'm
saying he understood his job
and he understood the plumbing of the
financial system and he understood
what needed to keep the wheels on the
bus
and keep it going that's not jenny ellen
but what about jerome powell
i know you've been uh pretty outspoken
about janet yellen what are your
thoughts on jerome i mean look
his net worth is somewhere between 150
million dollars i think he's done wow
february 2022 his his term is up
and the woman who donated to hillary
clinton lal brainerd
is poised to rise that's who you think
is going to be the next chairman of the
fed
chairwoman of the fed i think so well we
got prediction here by the way if you're
enjoying the podcast so far smash that
subscribe button you mean moreno thank
you for the hundred dollars you just
gave to the podcast so
now short sellers and elon musk you know
last week we talked about
i asked a question from adam and tom i
said
who's next to be permanently banned from
twitter that's as you know that's you
know like trump you know you got trump
personality permanently banned from
twitter
and i brought up to uh ilamas because
you know some of the stuff he talks
about hey
he's very influential very very
influential he's got a lot more look
what he did to bitcoin then he plays
with bitcoin look what he does with
short him he's just playing
non-stop right so is what he's doing
okay is what he's doing with twitter is
is he that brilliant where he's not
crossing the line and he's just playing
games with the market to show how much
influence he has
well if it was elon musk in a vacuum
maybe so
but he's the pied piper so he has plenty
of people following
every move he makes so you can't say
bitcoin's the next it girl and then a
few days later be like i'm just kidding
it you're you're toying with small
investors
and speaking of elizabeth warren so and
you've got gary gensler coming in
in the uh in the securities and exchange
commission
and he's looking into these influential
type of
voices so but i'm gonna push back for
just two seconds
and say it was a strange it was a bad
line that was crossed when they took
donald trump off twitter
it just was it set a bad precedent
because now we can have these
conversations about who's next
and that's not what free speech is all
about it's not
so you're for trump staying on
i i think that the precedent that was
set is a bad thing
it's kind of like the democrats saying
kind of like aoc
cut lover saying we need to get rid of
the filibuster it's like well wait a
minute
if if the midterms flip the house and
the senate in 2022 which is
perfectly viable then and you got rid of
the filibuster how are you going to like
that then
so you need to watch what you do because
you're setting the next generation
of precedent when you do it and it could
come back to bite you in the ass
yeah dorsey doesn't seem like he's gonna
flip on that he's sticking to it he
doesn't sound like he's gonna do
anything about it but let's talk about
elizabeth warren you brought it up you
brought it up
she proposed attacks on the wealthy u.s
billionaires would have paid a combined
114 billion dollars for 2020 under an
ultra millionaire tax that senate
senator elizabeth warren
proposed and the way the bill works is
anything you have 50 million dollars
network anything above it it's a two
percent tax
on your current wealth anything above a
billion
is a three percent tax on top of your
billion that you would owe based on all
the wealth
uh american billionaires at the end of
2020 a decade of wealth on them
would fund about three quarters of
presidents joe biden's 1.9
trillion dollar chronovirus relief
packet so they're kind of trying to get
the money back for that a separate
analysis of the university of uc
berkeley which
again janet yellen estimated that the
tax would generate
three trillion dollars in revenues over
the next 10 years an interesting study
done by uc
berkeley amazon jeff bezos would have
paid 5.7 billion dollars in wealth
taxes in 2020 bezos would have paid two
elon musk would have paid uh 4.6 gates
would have paid 3.6 zuck would have paid
3 billion
thoughts on the wealth tax she's tried
it before
i remember that so like you have to have
buy-in from your own party
and at last check the democrats were no
longer a party for the people
they've long since sold themselves out
to corporate sponsors so
they have to be on board where did you
find fresca
you want a fresco you want one yes i
will get you a fresca
that's amazing oh yeah fresco but
fresca's a
it's a it's a really hard to get your
hands on
it is but we have connections with us we
got guys we got here from columbia we
got a fresco
laura laura and so sam and laura she'll
be here yeah
you're going to get your egg sponsor
like in five minutes because because
they're going to trade you for free
today's podcast is sponsored by
now look she's tried this before um
the the figures sound like they're big
but to a lot of these
multi-billionaires they're rounding
errors and
for anybody who's offended by it they're
just going to leave just look at what's
happened with new york
and new jersey and the people who have
moved to the great state of florida
because they're offended by bad tax
policies
these things never work out the way they
seem and but it they make for really
good sound bites
they they do do they though do they when
she goes out there and saying like i'm
sitting there wondering saying
okay you do wealth tax on your next
campaign you need wall street to fund
you what are they going to say to you
what are you talking about exactly
that's what i'm talking about that's
something she's not gonna get buying
from her own party it's almost as if
she's permanently disqualifying herself
of ever running
and winning anything but that's her job
and she'll get reelected
she'll be in the grave and she'll still
be in office but not not at the highest
level
you talk about what she's doing right
now of course yeah yeah that makes sense
what are your thoughts on it i guess my
my question is well number one the tax
code in america is
ridiculous i mean i i it's the most
complicated thing just
you make a hundred grand a year to do
your taxes it's very difficult so now
you're talking about
these people who are worth billions and
billions of billions in the tax codes
and the loopholes and the
tax write-offs and this and that you
know i'm i'm the more and more i hear
about flat tax obviously ross perot
simplified simplify it keep it simple
the more and more like i think about it
i'm agreeing with adam he's very smart
today with his life
but all right but here's here's where
i'm gonna flip it and not be so smart
this is why you get the comments that
you get sometimes where people come
after soyboy mafia but go ahead tell us
you know what the thick skin all right
bro
i got thick glasses things he hasn't
shaved for a while so he's got an even
bigger layer of protection
though flat flat tags but by the way we
just found out today that a young rudy
giuliani
and a young adam would never
be in adam's league right isn't that
what it is i would never date a young
hot julia
never yeah i would like to know the art
i would like to get in hot in
we were having a conversation before the
podcast put a young rudy giuliani
picture up
oh my gosh okay we're gonna do this
we're gonna do this yeah
here i am putting my glasses i'm trying
to talk taxes by the way
back here you heard this adam thinks
he's a dime okay adam
adam thinks there aren't many men better
looking than him in the world but go to
a young rudy giuliani
look at that yeah look go too
look at that right there that's a great
guy okay zero to ten what are you
running three comb
over he's a twelve he's not a twelve but
he's at least a seven
you say okay let's see at least a seven
seven you called him a good looking guy
and i questioned you wait a minute what
is good looking to you
i think i think he's a good looking guy
look at that i think that's a good look
what's wrong with that look
at the what about the one on the left
right there kai go down you're going
down you're going down and stop bop
right there what about that picture
which picture the one where his face is
falling off and melting buddy he is how
old in that picture that's right now
you think you're gonna look good but
here's my point like you think you're
gonna look like this
beautiful looking handsome face you got
going on i gotta say you guys still have
your hair so
you have no idea the point that i was
making about giuliani because obviously
you took shots at us
people want to hear about my thoughts on
taxes they can't wait to hear my
thoughts on taxes i get it
my point with giuliani is here we go
three words
fall from grace this was america's mayor
we're talking about what a mess
new york city is we're talking about
cuomo we're talking about de blasio
danielle mentioned why can't we get
someone like giuliani back and i said
yes
i said yes he was the man in the 90s
cleaned up the mafia
cleaned up the streets took the trash
out 911 he was america's mayor he was a
hero
and now he's in 11 and he was and now
he's here now he's a punch line and a
borat movie his face is leaking he's
doing press conferences in front of four
seasons porno shop
think about it he's had a fall from
grace think about the two men who were
on the pile
the pile in downtown new york debbie
and giuliani yeah whose legacy is intact
who didn't say a
word through all of trump's
administration and obama and obama he
totally graceful his legacy is probably
better now than it was when he left
office when he left office he was well
wait a minute
are you suggesting the strategy is to
disappear and don't do anything no no
that was his strategy i don't and by the
way i mean we
we had bush at our event a year and a
half ago and i got to tell you when we
had 100 people that took pictures with
them this is pre-covet
you know what was the most common thing
everybody said to him they said
you know president bush i got to tell
you i thought you were the auntie i
thought you were
i thought you were the devil i thought
and i i've just fallen in love with you
today oh my gosh i didn't know there was
this this this
he got 63 of the hispanic vote in the
state of texas when he
when he ran for governor the second time
of hispanics solid right uptight white
boy
yeah yeah so you've got a lot but he he
would have a beer with
a man of the people yeah no longer he
would have a beer with you but
he was true yeah no longer because he
changed his life after
you know an incident i think what he did
okay
so you like his flat taxes that's what
you're saying oh back to that
i think what george w bush clearly his
biggest mistake was
um you know invading iraq and west's
weapons of mass destruction
essentially you know this is a change i
mean
um and what did he do
since he's left office not do anything
stupid
giuliani opens doors to just like
where can i open the stupid door and he
just walks right into it you know i
i had a i had a friend of mine that i
gave this advice to one time
i said you know you know what your
biggest challenge is he says what's
what's that
i said uh when there's crisis i never
worry about you
he says why i said because you're always
going to come out of it 100
you're going to come out of it i said
but when there's no crisis and
everything's good i worry about you he
says why i said because you freaking
create crisis oh is that his deal
you don't like to be in peace giuliani
is a freaking wartime guy he needs that
he feels he needs the drama
yeah but that also means sometimes when
you get into a street fight you're gonna
get your ass kicked and they're gonna
show that highlight of a knockout
and your name is tyson getting knocked
out by buster douglas that's going to
happen this is what happens with
giuliani
politicians politicians need a
hippocratic oath
first do no harm if there's nothing
going on shut your mouth yeah and that's
what george w
bush did he said about the point i was
going to wrap up with yeah
but some retire on time
some continue playing basketball and
their legacy looks bad
there's timing in retirement like bush
disappeared legacy got better
right yeah some stay in the mix too long
and then there's too many opportunities
to screw up because and then there's tom
brady hello
yeah seven which is right and by the way
he's still continuing first question his
wife asked after they won seven is what
is this enough like what do you need to
do next there's no i gotta go so what
else do you need in your life says i
need the eighth
he said why the eight so can you imagine
the wiring
go back to your flat taxes mr uc
berkeley union uh labor economy we're
going back to the flat tax black taxes
is going to
take a very although i'm with
adam on this if you want to if you want
warren buffett to
to pay more taxes than his secretary
then just tax him
don't do you don't get rid of all of the
cpas you know when you have an economist
with something that i just came up with
over here
if you want to get rid of all of the
there's just
red tape then just do it just
just tax them period so you're good with
flat tax
i think it should be in the conversation
again i think everything should be on
the table
not everything but what are the chances
of flat what are the chances
here's danielle salute cheers pbd i got
grapefruit what do you got you got uh i
have black cherry
black cherry here give me a toast toast
and and whitey's egg whites thank you uh
whities
so okay so flat taxes who would be
against flat taxes rich people
i thought poor people would be against
flat taxes that's crazy right that you
would think that i would
because if you're if you're taxing
everyone at fifteen percent
no no i mean in theory the rich are
getting 40
the poor are paying you know nothing you
just don't tax them if they make a
certain amount or less if
they're below the poverty line you just
don't tax them period by the way i think
that's a great idea
i think that's a great idea if you make
below a second
better than a welfare system by the way
here's the thing watch this watch
this this just took us to a completely
different place which would you rather
have you guys ready
which would you rather honestly i'm
asking this to everybody listen to this
what she just said we're in the
different free we just made a right
u-turn we're going this way watch this
yeah would you
rather have a minimum wage
or if you make less than 40 grand a year
you don't pay any taxes
hello which would you take no tax
forget the minimum wage are you
seriously a minimum wager i'm not a
minimum wager
what shirt was he wearing last week i
love 15
bring it you know like fight for 15.
okay all right
here's a little lesson danielle before
you rip me a new one
he's making that up before you go in on
me
i'm gonna do this all right i do have a
friend
i do one of my best friends in in south
florida
he's a guy um that he's he is the
champion of the president
you have a friend in south florida okay
yes everywhere you go you run into
somebody that knows this guy here
adamites you call them atomizers
yeah they're out there subway mafia so
but but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah get me a
new one give me a new one
my my mama was born and raised in
pearsall texas
the the average home price in pearson
texas is around 73 000
my father was born and raised in east
haven connecticut it's east of new haven
average home price there's about 250
thousand dollars
should the average worker make 15 in
pearsall
and in east haven clearly not okay good
see next this is why i'm against a
federal minimum wage but in certain
connecticut rich areas or you know south
florida boca raton there needs to be
you've never been east haven it's
not it's not it's not where it's at it's
not the right side of no uh danielle can
you get used to being in boca raton more
often i just want to know that i'm so
loving it here guys okay
cause i heard from the people at louis
bosses you had a great time last night
oh my gosh
they called me this morning they said oh
by the way management team yeah by the
way
yes we want danielle back give her a
second wake-up call yes
so okay so you are in favor of of
governors or mayors implementing some
sort of minimum wage but not federal
government
did i understand that correctly it is
the job of this is why we have the
separation
all i was saying is i mean let's take
the camera off i'm trying to see if
paulo's paying attention so if i signal
to you that's what i mean but don't
worry about it you missed the signal
everybody else caught what i was saying
there's an egg white signal okay no no
the egg white signal to paul is get off
your instagram
well you guys are dming your girl okay
and you know i'm watching but you guys
are pregnant
but we know that's not a truth sixth
place
stop that buddy my god so paul and
you and brady are going for right here
yeah yeah honestly
danielle i know this was just accidental
how we got into the conversation
i'm actually just this if you actually
pitched
you make less than 30 grand or 40 grand
don't pay any taxes
but let's eliminate minimum wage so so
meaning
if you're making 7.20 an hour 7.25 an
hour whatever the number is right now 15
grand well you're making more you
you know no you pick the number you're
you're making 10 bucks in our other job
20 grand a year 20 grand a year if
you're making 10 bucks an hour 20
if you were to pay taxes how much are
they taking taxes out of you if you're
making 10 bucks an hour well i don't
think you pay any taxes if you make less
than i think
12 grand or 10 grand like zero that's on
zero tax i'm saying
40. okay take minimum wage out no taxes
paid
until you make 40 grand sure so the only
number we deal with
is what raising or lowering that number
not minimum wage
so which means i like that if we go four
years from now five years from now 10
years from now due to inflation that 40
goes 45.
that 45 goes 50. you don't pay any taxes
below that if you make about 50 you pay
taxes
i mean i'm in eliminate eliminate
eliminate the minimum wage minimum wage
and
yep and eliminate minimum wage and
eliminate
the the progressive tax just put a flat
tax on you're going to make government
work
why is government going to work what do
you mean it's going to work you do
something that simple government
actually works
it functions that is an incredible why
don't
why aren't these kind of conversations
you give me frosting on the cake of term
limits and we're all good i mean look at
look at pat toomey pat timmy's my hero
oh my gosh i've got like the pat to me
poster on my ceiling right toomey's your
hero
tournaments and sticking to them is it
pennsylvania where's pennsylvania
pennsylvania pat toomey
democrat no what is that to me i don't
know you know but he's
moderate did he vote against trump he is
a moderate and he did
he voted against trump insurrection i
love how
adam says to me but i mean look at
people like maxine waters i'm not that
i'm not
who have been in congress for decades
and decades and decades they're just
taking up space
they're not legislating they're not
governing they're not doing anything for
the people
yeah like that one guy what's that one
guy he just won the presidency what's
his name
oh buy it just takes up space stop it
what's that one guys do i'm getting
assaulted here
you know he hasn't done a press
conference yet either who is that joe
biden there's tons of articles who is
that who was that press conferences are
a [ __ ] without a teleprompter
yeah and they cut out his i got i said
that out loud he was like okay
more than me and that's a problem
because you know whoa whoa
whoa all right let's talk about governor
abbott let's talk about government
because this one's about to get really
exciting here danielle's governor
to put it no longer ours is desantis
which i don't think she's a fan of
desantis either but we'll talk about
both of them okay
so governor abbott announced his plan to
fully reopen businesses
ending state mass mandate tax republican
governor turns on these problems
100 percent abbott issued an executive
order that resents
many of the state's previous orders
allowing all businesses in the state to
fully reopen and revoke in the statewide
mandate to be clear covet has not
like suddenly disappeared said governor
abbott
responsibly kovitz still exists in texas
the united states
and across the globe but it is clear
from the recoveries
the vaccinations from the reduced
hospitalizations
and from the safe practices texans are
using the state mandates are no longer
needed
businesses are able to limit capacity or
implement additional safety protocols
if they choose to which is wonderful
he's leaving it up to you
you know danielle to choose and say we
believe you should wear a mask it's a
choice right
and uh governor newsome quickly
responded to the announcement on tuesday
oh
calling it absolutely reckless in a
twitter post
newsome has a lean towards stricter
guidelines
in california's pandemic response
danielle what are your thoughts on your
governor
well uh i think that he was a little
upset with the straw poll at cpac that
gave him a zero percent probability of
being president in 2024.
so you think this is because of that oh
yes i think he needed a
he needed a moment he's looking for
headlines oh yeah
let me ask you do you think he wants to
run
oh let let's see one two three how many
times did he visit
the white house four times when trump
was there
so you think he wants to run i think
every governor
has aspirations especially when it's
this
ninth largest economy on the planet okay
you're saying if you get to that
level where you're the governor you have
to have aspirations you you have
such high lofty aspirations you could
see yourself being president
you're florida's former governor is in
the senate now
let's do this but let's so you touched
up on one part of the whole thing so
he announces he's opening it up 100 and
he leaves it to you business owners in
texas
i'm one in texas i have a big decent
sized business in texas
i've heard that if we want to open it up
we can open it up if not we don't open
it up right
you say it's because he got zero percent
chance from cpac running again
and that hurt his feelings so he wanted
to get relevant hey here's what we're
doing
uh and all of a sudden media he gets a
few hundred thousand likes on twitter
everyone's talking about it everyone's
saying yes no
disagreeing but how about the actual
mandate how about actually lifting it
what are your thoughts on lifting
and putting it at a hundred percent and
getting people back to work
getting people back to work i think
small business owners that are not able
to get that has
been getting now that's that's that's a
red herring
getting people back to work look at how
you run your company
people individuals in their cubicles
they have their own mandates in terms of
who can get close and who can't
so you run your business responsibly
every business can be open
opening bars at 100 is asinine
it just is you're assuming people are
going to be responsible and they won't
be
look there's a reason that life
expectancy in asia is
longer than it is here in the united
states there's a reason that we didn't
have a flu season
in the united states we were all
protected from one another
so there's something to be said for not
getting sick
there just is look but again
it should be up to
the business owner but you need to have
a responsible governor
you just do it but but i'm sorry daniel
i'm confused so
so you are saying leave it to the small
business owner to decide whether you
were
public places though sure wear the mask
okay or you're saying but in public
places he should say
you should wear a mask in public places
in public places such as
when i'm out when i'm running when i'm
walking
then then you're new some then you're
like no outdoor dining what an idiot
okay so you're not newsom you're not
abbott what are you what
i'm in between i'm trying to ensure that
people are as responsible as they should
be
did you enjoy dinner last night at louis
boston i did how was it it was great how
where were you sitting at when you ate
the bar how many people were at the bar
tons tons why did you do
that i but we were not
all over each other well you know we're
not people are not all over each other
in texas they have a little bit more
etiquette they'll say hey i'm sorry
wait wait wait wait wait people in texas
have more etiquette uh i think more than
florida i like that poker runs home
no florida they're they're very listen
here this is like
people who are like do you know who i am
the etiquette here is do you know who i
am
the etiquette in texas is a little bit
different there's a lot of new yorkers
here so your customer service in florida
is not texas customer service
that's true so so but you enjoyed
yourself last night
i did but i think that there's a certain
amount of
comfort that you get in knowing that
other people have masks on did you send
the tweet thanking the santas
did you say governor desantis thank you
for allowing me to eat at louis bosses
and enjoy this italian food and the
glass he's also my favorite person
he's so but here's desantis so
how do you feel about this hashtag
sarcasm hello all right i have taken it
out how do you feel about now desantis
on the other end
you know abbott got zero percent but
desantis on the other end
oh huge okay so mr c yes
so he is a star in a making that
actually has potentially what it takes
to be your president
maybe mine may be his but he could be
our president right
what are your thoughts about desantis
i'm actually curious to know what you're
going to say about desantis
so here we go in the florida panhandle
over the summer
when i came here with my family to
vacation as i do
every year i got away from destin
and the more crowded rosemary's i i took
a step
further beyond that and i only went into
walmart's
because it sounds like my kind of party
because they mandated masks
when he wouldn't in the middle of
a wave of covet
and making teachers go back into the
classroom
when they should have maybe stayed out
for seven days which he
amazingly did it's just
you say that's irresponsible right
totally qualified irresponsible but he
doesn't care
okay you you have a certain appeal
if you appeal to
the rebel to the trump there there's a
trump and a lot of people
if you appeal to that person you're
going to make
all kinds of brownie points you're going
to be really
popular at cpac oh i don't think that's
it though i don't think it's just that i
i'm talking pure results
is what i'm talking about so the
unemployment rate in the state of
florida
is not any better or worse than it is in
the united states
yeah but it's way better than new york
and california so seriously
so go to the people that were
ridiculously
that that's that's what friends et
cetera et cetera and what they did
they're an american but here's my here's
my argument for the sentence here's my
argument for the sentence and my
argument for abbott
okay um you know the story about
disneyland disney world this is not a
news story so disneyland you know you
know
they weren't working with bob iger same
company two companies and bob iger's a
democrat
newsome wasn't working with him you know
eventually he's like dude i'm not going
to disney
on easter yeah so back here disneyland
shuttle
25 000 employees lose their jobs disney
world's good to go they keep their jobs
so people are able to go feed their
families get the food pay the rent all
that other stuff
same ceo iger two separate governors
newsom
desantis helps disney stay in business
and the employees keep their job
knew some fires 25 i think maybe the
number is even 78 000 people i don't
know the exact number but
it was a big number that lost their jobs
right okay so
let's talk about a sport that would be
qualified as the most
liberal supporting sport in america
which one would you say that is
take the four sports basketball i think
it's versus nhl we don't even know what
nhl would be but nhl is
women's sport okay they have more female
fans than any other sport nhl nhl
by far it's not even funny we like to
watch men beat each other
yeah that's right okay so there you go
so
what what what sport is the sport that
supports blm liberal
and you know the social justice campaign
of the year which is clearly the nba
yeah
okay so the nba who would fully
disagree with desantis because of his
irresponsible actions he's here
decided to do their playoffs in florida
yeah the super bowl
decided to do their super bowl a super
bowl in florida
the sentence is trying to get olympics
to be
in florida why are people from new york
nearly a trillion dollars of wealth say
over half a trillion dollars of wealth
moving to the most irresponsible state
florida
why are so many californians leaving to
governor abbott state
why it if you if you sit there and you
look at it from my perspective the way i
see it he says
responsible make the decision small
business owners
do what you need to do responsibilities
on you let's do it right no problem with
that
yeah but i also think you know to to
lift what he did in texas
uh and what desantis did in florida i
think these guys came out being heroes
look what happened in new york every
single day we watched cuomo
every day we were watching cuomo you got
and you know how i feel about cuomo i've
said this
years ago you're a huge fan but wait a
minute i i never said i'm not
what i'm trying even until today i think
the guys the two brothers to me there's
an element of it that
i see family i see how their
thanksgiving would be i'm
i'm trying to interact a joke forget
politics i'm simply talking about
they're italians they're italians it's
like hey what's up and their dad mario
you just kind of feel that
you'd want to be at their house at
thanksgiving you know if you your friend
you're like hey cuomo i'm coming over
okay cool come on over family's waiting
for you unless you're a young woman
unless you're a young woman yeah unless
you're a young woman okay
so so again you know it started off
cuomo was a hero he's going to be the
next president
newsom is a hero oh he's so responsible
one guy's about to be recalled and the
other guy's about to be impeached
and desantis and abbott look like rock
stars
so kovitt kind of made abbott and
desantis look like
rock stars and the two other governors i
don't know about that
so and you know the irony
the irony is that if you look at the per
capita
death rate in these states they're all
kind of on top of each other
so for all of the overbearing
regulations that were
imposed in california it didn't save the
lives
that you can do you can go too far
that's what i'm saying i don't
i don't mind a mask mandate in public
areas but let
business owners do whatever they need to
do to be in business
well i'm glad i lived in texas and for
five years i'm glad i moved my
headquarters from california to texas
and i'm glad i'm in the state of florida
i cannot tell you how safe i feel
uh as a business owner as a small
business owner entrepreneur i am glad
i'm in these two states because
i have offices all over california i'm
all over northeast i'm all over dmv
but you can over deregulate that's
what's been happening
with those two states because guess who
was in austin during icemageddon
musk himself he was none too impressed
yeah so you can you can go too far
on either end of the spectrum 2011 sure
there was a super bowl there was ice
everywhere the power grid failed
the power grid ercot in texas said we're
going to fix it 2014
failed again we're really going to fix
it this time
we're going to take those suggestions to
weatherize yeah our power plants
a few years later 2021 people die
and it's a third world experience so you
can go
too far in terms of not having
regulations
i don't disagree it was very
disappointing all i said is how's a
state
this big wasn't prepared for the storm
that they had right how
how's that even possible but at the same
time danielle if we flip it
how does a state like california every
flipping year loose people to fire
and it's not a one-time thing at least
texas this is the worst they've ever had
in a hundred years
how does texas california every year you
got the fire everything you can't figure
it out
they wrote the book on how to not run
your power grid california did
texas had at least had an example to
follow yeah the mudslides
the fires every it's just you have to
want to be there
so really badly because you get the
weather from florida
yeah but you get the taxes from
california who would do that to be aware
who would live in california with those
taxes
quite a lot of people third largest
economy fifth largest economy the
largest economy in the world i get it i
get it i get it
i'm out there once a year but who would
pay those taxes i just don't get it
when you can live and and so many
companies are agreeing
yeah and that's why on my twitter feed
all the californians when texas was
freezing
there was just the the word is
schadenfreude they were so excited that
there were people suffering in texas
and i'm like are you serious yeah of
course they were nasty
yeah and like you're supposed to be you
know people from the happy state
it's unfortunate that's not america
though but that is
a lot of voters on both sides you know
there's a lot of voters on both sides
that that
that's why they call it the left coast
yeah well just a quick point on like why
would you live in california
i'll give a case example we would hear
for years and years and years new
yorkers are considering coming to
florida and like every new year is like
oh the new yorkers are here
you know oh why would you live in new
york why would you live in new york well
you know well you know the taxes and the
weather
but it took a freaking pandemic and zoom
and being able to work from remote for
people to say like you know what i'm
leaving new york before covet
yeah but not in droves like this no not
interesting and that's my point with
california is now with zoom
and wfh work from home and work from
anywhere
now you have that luxury whereas jp
morgan you didn't have that luck
for lease 800 000 square feet of office
property
jp morgan's going to have a bigger
footprint employee-wise in texas than
it's going to have in new york
800 000 square feet of office space in
new york
pat wants to see states like new york
and california be completely
flipped on its on its head do you know
you need to run you you need a young
rudy giuliani you just do
a young hot roodie you're so funny okay
he was never hot if we just said he was
good looking i mean
don't don't go too far seven or eight
that's all i said he's a seven or eight
seven or an eight it's like a five and a
half step
what would you say you're you are what
are you adam seven or eight no you're
not seven or eight
i i put you as an eight and a half but
you know
i'm more obsessed with rudy giuliani
[Music]
you were vouching for rudy giuliani i
thought that he's kind of gross
one of the best-looking guys i know how
about that one of the best-looking guys
i know
if i'm one of the best-looking guys in
this room you know i know a lot of
good-looking guys yeah you're one of the
best-looking guys
okay so so let's let's continue by the
way by the way so so we talked about
texas they
did what they did target toyota gm and
macy's in texas keep wearing masks which
is fine do your thing
employees at gm toyota something in
texas will keep their masks on the
company said on tuesday even as the
state lifted okay good
abby's executive order left okay got it
we know that relaxing common sense
safety protocols like wearing masks is a
mistake
jason brewer vice president
communication at state affairs of retail
industry leaders association state
said adding that going back on safety
measures will unfairly put
retail employees back in a role of
enforcing guidelines still recommended
by the cdc okay
there was 35 other states puerto rico as
of monday 35 u.s states will
along with district of columbia and
puerto rico mandate the residents wear
masks in public iowa mississippi montana
north dakota
have lifted mass orders earlier
as well so you know you're looking at
this what are the other 11 states that
i've done in montana iowa north dakota
mississippi
georgia florida south carolina georgia
was never even
georgia's never even had a mass man yeah
they've never mandated a mask mandate so
again i mean we'll see what's going to
happen the reality of it is every time
these types of decisions are made
every time these types of decisions are
made all the you know one
one lady came out and she said she
tweeted she said uh
i just want you to know this is a very
irresponsible decision
i will never i'm a texan i will never le
uh
go anywhere without wearing a mask
matter of fact i'm double masking right
now when i go out so great do it
that's your business she said i hope
they don't force me to take my mask off
i said no one's going to force you to
take my ass
off what are you talking about i said i
said for how many decades have you gone
to the airport and you see folks flying
from asia with them and i would always
say why they put their masks on like
what happens in asia you know
why do they have a lot a longer life
expectancy yeah so
so so yeah you think it's because of the
mask versus the food they eat and the
how common peaceful they are in the
mediterranean diet but they also don't
have a
lot of season like we do i mean they
just they believe that germs are not for
sharing
so but it's just a way of life i don't
know i think but look at what their
economies have done
in a in a covered world so many of their
economies have not been hit hard well
china is the only
um country i'm not talking i'm not i'm
not talking about i'm just saying china
is the only country in the world to have
a positive gdp for 2020.
that's the only country that was
actually what a deceptive thing that was
that
that was actually fake math sorry yeah
well well you're going to trust china
that's what you're saying
we can't trust you what you do i know
you get your data from china only i only
get a cnn china news network
i'm sorry like uh they went they went
back into 2019
and revised economic data in order to
mathematically
fabricate no country had a positive gdp
oh
so even china but countries like other
there were there were a lot of countries
that did a lot better
true but why would china like walk me
through you know
china's mentality here why would they
want to be known as the only country to
have a positive gdp
because they wouldn't that put a more of
a target on their back from
you caused this and you're doing and
you're succeeding through all this and
when the rest of us are melting away
you think they care well no obviously
not all right walk me through this thing
i just got the ccp off my damn twitter
feed and you just need to be quiet now
they were they were they finally went
away they were what
they created all these impersonators on
twitter accounts
china's moderating you damn
look they have their eye on the prize
they have their eye on on patrick's
2025.
they do they and
we're focused on the midterm elections
right by the way
the one thing about china you gotta
respect man they are so
united at the top like what when do you
hear
a polit no obviously it's communism and
it's foreign i totally get it
yeah but xi jinping was a quiet
bureaucrat before he rose up and became
stronger than mao yeah so you have to
you have to think about
in u.s like the the as much as
you know what the constitution was
written i wouldn't want to live anywhere
else
it also reveals too many of who's
against who
all you have to do is watch the news for
like a couple he's like okay he hates
him
she hates her they're on the same page
it looks like they're
on the same team okay good here's why
we're gonna negotiate boom boom boom
boom boom i mean it's so
easy to go up against us because you
know
hey well you know what uh trump said
about you the other day when we're
talking i just want to make sure that
you know that we have your back and
you don't think these types of things
are being played on a behind the like
have you ever had anybody that tried to
manipulate and negotiate and you're kind
of sitting there like wow you are so
freaking good you would probably get a
lot of other people the way you just did
patrick let's just face it you're ten
times better than you know
uh bobby and i know bobby's your boss
and i know this but
let's face it without you he's a nobody
and you know they're like
wow you are so deceptive buddy wow
just sitting there listening to the
language uh you know
adam you know if i was your girlfriend
you don't like a girl says that
you're liking likes you're like oh you
would oh really you would treat me
better okay that's great you know you're
done
you're done we're going so we're just
giving our dirty laundry to the world
and saying hey
use this against us come on down and
it's making it so easy
but that's not new right we've been
doing that for you hundred something
years
not 200 something years not 200
something years because 200 something
years ago
media wasn't the way it was fair enough
so when they came out with what what
they came about back in the days you
didn't say something
two seconds later china already knows
what you said you said something
it may take two months until they find
out what you just said
okay so the speed of being able to
retaliate wasn't that quick when they
wrote the constitution today
i say something right now china could
have somebody watching us to make sure
we don't say anything bad about china
they have one job
monitor these podcasts to see what
they're saying specifically these guys
because she said stuff about china he
said stuff about china he said stuff
about china
we don't know this stuff on what they're
doing so easy for them to
do it today versus what it was 200 years
ago anyways
and they do it with no fear remember the
international court system came out when
barack obama was in office and said
china is violating international law
with
building out the south china sea and
they're still doing it
and they're still doing it because the
united states looked the other way so
and now we have his protege bottom line
80 years old we've been talking about
china doing all you know stealing
intellectual property
breaking international law for a
generation for generation
wtf like what are we like is there going
to be a hot war are we is there a cold
war is it trade war
like what in the end is actually going
to happen or we're just going to talk
about it and talk about it and talk
about that
like the bitcoiners will tell you that
bitcoin is going to take over
but that means that the past 400 years
of history is gone
history because in the past 400 years if
you're going to lose
the reserve currency status which means
you rule the world there's been a hot
war involved
and that's just history there has been a
hot war
and who is building up their military
for the first time since world war
ii germany and who is now more reliant
on china for their economic growth
than they used to be from the united
states germany
so china is an interesting thing because
if you look where they're investing
money
in 2016 they put more money into the
united states than they did in
europe and then trump won and they quit
putting money into the united states and
they started putting money into europe
and if you think about world history and
building alliances and world wars and
hot wars
you cannot have a hot war unless you
have an alliance
and that's what china's building very
proactively
who's on china's team what i mean we
know that they're pumping money into
iran as an example and they're pumping
money into certain countries into africa
for sure but who's like i'm with china
no doubt what's up
look at look at south america and all of
the copper
soybean look at the exports look look at
who has pumped up
that entire subcontinent's economy in
the last generation
so these are they have built out the
infrastructure and energy in africa
but i'm talking the big countries the
big countries of the world did i mention
germany
okay so germany's on team china not team
united states is what you're saying
they're not on team eu
it remains to be seen we all know what
happens when freaking germany gets a
freaking
uh army on its side but but again
germany is building up its military
well you're saying well you're saying
alex you're saying allies united states
knows that we have
canada up here we've got uh you know
obviously every pretty much every
country in the eu we've got australia
we've got certain countries
all over the world that have our back no
matter what i mean we've got differences
what have you
what can you say about china who like is
russia have china's back
iran of course okay those two are there
saudi arabia saudi arabia it's on whose
side
china china we're on our way
to being independent energy-wise
so we don't rely on the opec nations as
we once did it
where is this going to culminate i guess
is my point is that we talk about it we
talk about it china's doing this china's
doing that so they're going to take us
over 2020 we started talking about 1.9
trillion dollars that's not gonna
that's not going towards job creation
we're still on the first topic by the
way we're back to bitcoin
1.9 trillion dollars um okay
i mean you know
it's not even closed and well first of
all enemy number one is internal is
within u.s it's a mindset but i think
outside of that it's china
i don't think enemy number one just
touched on a great set it
the united states is its own worst enemy
exactly i i uh
this is this is uh unfortunately i've
lived in other countries and i had the
benefit
of living in three different states in
america and what i mean i also lived in
kentucky and tennessee but i'm talking i
lived in three different states as a
business executive right
i lived in kentucky i lived in kentucky
he's in the army yeah when i was in the
army i lived in kentucky south carolina
and tennessee for
two and a half three years so but and i
lived in iran i lived in germany so you
have an
experience and politically on one side
mom's side one side that side one side
you know america is cracks me up on some
americans who have what they have they
keep taking shots at america it's very
very weird for me when i see it
very weird for me so i do think number
one enemy is america
itself then i think it's how do we heal
that though like within ourselves
like before we start fighting with china
how are we going to heal that internally
i don't think you're going to be able to
let me explain to you why because
if if the only so so
who stokes it think about like who who
gets the who fires us up who divides us
who pins us against each other
for as long as there's a business model
for that this is not going away you're
saying the media
yeah for as long as there's a there's a
business model for media this is not
going away
they're not making money right now okay
the cnn foxes are not making money right
now
you're not watching cnn fox as much as
you used to a year ago you're not
watching
the trump [ __ ] show well because biden
is not doing any press conferences
biden's been instructed by his team to
not get on tv and talk biden's not
saying anything that's oh my could you
hear what he said he's making only for
four years
the life of the media a living hell
nothing
they don't have a job right now there is
there is still more coverage of donald
trump
than there is of biden today of course
in the media
the major media that's what media needs
media needs an enemy
unfortunately the enemy is america so
the media's enemy
is part of their team so for example
let's talk about cuomo right let's talk
about cuomo real quick what happened on
draculauma this whole sexual harassment
thing that took place and another person
came out another person came out
charlotte bennett came out 25-year
former aide you know and you see the
picture with him on the hands on the
face
this is an inside job okay and all these
other things and you're saying okay
you know age doesn't matter he told her
as he asked about her feelings about age
differences relationship conversation
she told a friend about texas
he's fine with anyone about the age of
21. she said he told her
okay and all this stuff and comatose
relationship celebrity sandra lee his
girlfriend for 14 years ended in 2019
and then his brother gets heat right hey
chris cuomo criticized
for hypocrisy after he said he won't
cover brother's controversy cnn
chris is going to violence before we
start tonight let me say something that
i'm sure it's very obvious
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother and obviously and i
can't i cannot cover it because he
is my brother right he is my brother
that there's a natural conflict there's
a natural conflict there so first of all
what are your thoughts about what's
going on with andrew coleman and we'll
talk about his brother and then
this all comes back to me with what i
was talking about with
america is undermining their own
american like their own allies
internally versus china
the point will get there but what are
your thoughts about what happened with
andrew this smells like an inside job to
me this smells like it's coming from
within the democratic party
it's too orchestrated it's too organized
it it everything is so scripted you're
like they've been waiting for their
moment
they have and i don't know what the
democrats have against this guy but this
was
not something from outside the
democratic party what makes you even
instinctively go to go there right like
why
because the democrats are coming out
against him they're the ones calling for
him to be
okay so step down let's go with that
like why are they even thinking
all right we got to take this man down
is because all the deaths of the nursing
home
is it because that the nursing
regulation the nursing home scandal
is definitely um because again he
presented himself as the perennial
governor i'm doing everything right i'm
going to write a book about it
it's all about me me me me and then you
have this scandal erupt
and you've got the second highest per
capita death rate in the country after
new jersey
it it doesn't look good do you think
this is these are the dems within
the new york government within all the
dems
yes absolutely the the bellagios of the
world or even the state government
cannot stand so they got internal
public public hatred between those two
but why though why so why are
i do agree it's an inside job but why
are they coming after this guy
he's a candidate he could be a face he
could be a marketable guy
why are you going after cuomo is it
because you know the democrats there's
two democrats right now you got the aoc
bernie sanders side of the democrats and
then you have the democrats that biden
all the rest of the mansions
yeah so so my people yeah so what what
uh uh who which which group is going out
because every
they asked nancy pelosi yes they have to
go out there and investigate it they're
irresponsible they asked the mayor the
velocity yes that
i mean it's like everybody is throwing
them under the bus
you know whether it's the bite inside
the biden camp or the other side they're
all thrown under the bus
why is that there is they didn't like
his rise to power
they didn't like his hogging the
spotlight i mean i can't say i don't
know
but it is definitely an inside job and
by the way
you know like the things that came up
about him did you think anything was
severe like do you think anything was
out of control
look here oh god i can just hear my
twitter feed
there's nothing illegal about being a
dirty old man
dirty old man okay he didn't i mean he
didn't
there there wasn't i mean from from what
we've heard thus far there are no
allegations that
rent that wander into physicality right
right did you hear his press conference
yesterday did you hear him crying
yesterday or no
i crying i was on an airplane no did you
see him crying yesterday not no okay so
he apologized did you guys see it or no
he cried he
cried on national television
well we can't do it because they're
gonna they're not gonna let us play the
video because
they're not they're gonna flag it so he
could italian men cry
it happens yeah but he was crying he was
literally crying saying
he says at first it didn't seem but i
have to tell you i have come to a
conclusion
this was not okay what i did was not
okay and you know but
you know and yes i am gonna change my
approach and i shouldn't have done this
and he's crying while he's saying this i
can't
even cuomo crime while he's saying if
you're if you're the father of a
daughter would you want somebody talking
to your daughter like that no
you wouldn't but it's not a crime but
italian men they feel guilt they get all
emotional they say trust me
my uncle philip can crown a dime yeah
but you know you know how i processed
that here's how i got a daughter
and she looks like a cuclo and armenia
means like a doll
she's like look she looks like her mom
can i really prevent somebody flirting
with her
i don't know can can your husband
prevent you sitting on a flight with
another guy you know
on a flight flirting i don't know can
can folks in how many rich billionaires
do you know in their 60s that are dating
25 year olds i mean how many up
here it's very normal just so you know
it's very very normal here i've actually
noticed
okay yeah it's very normal here so so so
you know i think that's on the daughter
i think that's on the conversations with
the daughter of a
but i'm not gonna be telling her oh no
55 year old's ever gonna flirt with you
it's gonna happen it's inevitable if you
go to a bar it's just
so i for me it's like i sit and i say i
swear to god if somebody breaks my
daughter's heart i'm gonna kill this guy
right
what am i gonna do someone is gonna
probably end up doing this that's
irrational
yeah it's irrational if somebody beats
up my sons you know we're going to go
out there i'm going to meet their
parents
you know it's going to happen right so
it's happened for
all of you mankind the challenge is the
other day bill maher did a skit i sent
it to you i don't know if you're
watching
he talked about cancer culture and he
said are we really going to do this
by the way every i wish i could play it
for you so we can watch it together we
cannot
everybody needs to watch bill maher's
cancer if you send me
matter of fact six minutes it's six
minutes but you gotta watch it it's on
his instagram account save it
uh why don't you put the link somewhere
in the comment section later on once the
podcast's over for people to see it
you know he came from an angle like what
are we gonna do every single time
something comes out from fifth year
you know dr seuss is being cancelled
he's been dead what like
people are being now so originally it
was hearts being cancelled
comedians being cancelled actors being
cancelled businessmen being canceled and
now dead people are being cancelled so
what are you going to do future babies
that are going to be born being cancer
like what are we going to next at my
kids elementary school they had dr
seuss week and all the dads would sign
up
online and they would pick a dr seuss
book to go read
the kids i mean seriously
i have a random question i have a random
question this is a we
i was going to ask this before podcast
but i'm going to ask you guys
have you ever met anybody in your
lifetime that wasn't racist
that wasn't wasn't
that's a has a loaded question i think
everyone has
some sort of predisposition to well
this is racism right like what is racism
okay there
listen there's that person they're
freaking racist blatant racist
or there's people who are i think the
word you're looking for is
prejudice like you have sort of they
throw a predisposition
around the word racist pretty so so put
them together in the same family
prejudice racist stereotype just put
them on the same stereotypes
yeah but there's a difference between
okay so you grew up
italian on the east coast yeah so i mean
you grew up with polish jokes you just
do
do you really hate pollarks no you don't
but there's a difference between racism
and bigotry
but but okay who's not a bigot who's not
a lot of people
oh let me ask you a question do you
think do you think the same folks that
are
you know talking about uh what's going
on with blm you don't think they're
i was in the military i've worked in you
know regular jobs and i i cannot tell
you
how many i grew up not liking white
people because everybody that was in my
community saw white people as the rich
people
that have all the money and we work for
them you grew up you're like this
still exists i understand that what i'm
saying to you is
so for me i want to get my first job at
bally's i walk in i
had a beard at the time and i was pretty
big big guy at that time
so i walk in and you know i may not look
like the friendliest guy
so here you know the guy that hires me
later on says you know i gotta say i
don't like you at first i thought you
were this cocky arrogant middle eastern
guy that you know came in here and all
this stuff
and i was worried about having you being
here i said that's a form of
you know bigotry that is a form of
prejudice
that is a form of stereotyping
it's all middle easterns are judging a
book by its cover all middle easterners
are
dot dot dot all remember are all women
all whites are all i mean 9 11 after you
know
there were all these people taxi cab
drivers getting
beaten because they put every everybody
was in the same middle east
and the line is that that's crossing the
line
exactly i think targeting is crossing
the line yes i think
that is problematic well there's but but
just because somebody
you know there's a difference people
should have the right to not like you
people should have the right to say you
know what i just don't like your style
people should have the right to say
here's my they should have the right to
well i think there's a difference
between thoughts
between words and between actions so
everyone has thoughts like if i'm at an
atm
anyone who walks behind me i'm like
who's this mother you know like
it could be a five-foot woman i'm like
well you know like or your thoughts
but then taking it to a different level
all right words what are the jokes what
are the things you're saying what are
the comments you're making
and i guess that's a whole different
level that's like all right you've taken
your thoughts and now you've vocalized
them
i don't know about that and now when you
took it into action you start
beating people up because they look a
different way or
talking about physical abuse that's a
totally different the murder rate in the
united states is going through the roof
why though they have done extensive
studies and they have found that when
the
when there is a lack of confidence in
the political
leadership of the country come on guys
no i'm sorry but it's true oh come on
the
murder rate goes oh my gosh but is it is
that a study or what is it it is
okay i can send you're saying that you
don't believe that no it's not oh
my gosh guys what i'm trying to say
america may be the most
inclusive melting pot you are you
kidding me like
you turn on the tv it's like oh all
these people are bad people they're
after you because you're this skin color
and all this i'm like
no way there's this is probably
the greatest country in the world as far
as being
inclusive where we cannot now don't get
me wrong you go to alabama i remember i
went to alabama
and i uh went to waffle house guy comes
out
it's a guy comes out he says hey boy
i'm like uh patrick hey boy hey boy
where are you from boy
i said i'm from iran now what are you
doing here from iran
i said i'm in your military what do you
mean as
i'm in the u.s army at the 101st make
sure you're free i'm protecting you
yeah what do you say well well well
thank you for your service thank you for
your service
all right now let me get it back so so
the point is
listen i love america i served america
but i also understand
it's okay that some people are not going
to like me i don't wake up in the
morning saying oh my gosh you don't like
me when i started the insurance company
i had a negotiation with a guy said
we're going to drop your contract
because another three armenian insurance
companies
ripped them off took a million dollar
check away from them and they thought i
was going to do the same thing because
i'm armenian
i'm okay with that because i'm going to
change that
i'm going to give you my example we so
so for example if i were to right now
bring 10 girls different nationalities
to introduce them to you friends of mine
are we still looking for a wife or adam
well by the way you're still on the
search
i think by the way it wasn't eight and a
half i'm at eight eight right now just
so you know i'm at eight o'clock
something i didn't change
by the way with the mask you're a two so
this is why i don't want you to wear the
mask
i wanted to those why perfect white
teeth that you have to be shown right
so the point i'm trying to make to you
is i am so okay
if you you know think um such and such
because i'm from iran great let me earn
the right i'll earn the respect
i don't take it as but that's not fair
no i'm good i'll go earn the right
i'll go on the right and i'll earn the
respect i'm totally fine with that but
that's also the american way yeah yeah
but but today
today people are walking like this
people are walking like this with a
muzzle on their mouth and a handcuff and
shackle because they're
you're afraid to tell certain jokes like
a part of me wants to become a comedian
just to freaking
be free because you're a comedian it's
like let me just tell some jokes you
can't even talk nowadays you know i
didn't get the memo
apparently i'm still not politically
correct because i don't i don't have a
governor on my mouth
well no but you do but but but daniel
you do because
daniel and i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
go there but
you don't talk about a hundred percent
of things you believe in you talk about
98 percent of beliefs
you still have two percent that you and
i think you need to i'm not i'm not
judging that so i'm not saying oh go out
there and say everything you believe in
if we did that freaking people would be
like these guys belong in jail because
if you really thought about some of this
stuff publicly
it's good to keep some of it to yourself
right i don't have a problem with that i
think that's fine to have that
but all i'm saying is if that 98 is
getting pushed to 95 to 90 to 80 to 72
that's where we're going today we're
where comedians can't tell jokes are you
kidding me i want you to go tell your
jokes go
comedians ought to be free to go tell
your girlfriend
so let me bring you back to andrew cuomo
okay he said yes he says but i can tell
you one thing i didn't touch anybody
like meaning he didn't obviously touch
the face of the girl he didn't you know
grope or anything like he didn't use the
word grope that's what he's trying to
say
okay um where does flirting go
he's a single guy he's not married he's
flirting okay
where does that go you can't flirt is it
is it like are we at that
so what does floating become is this
floating hi i think you're pretty would
you like to go have a drink with me
i mean what so so what do you do like
that was not compelling yeah
that's not compelling so what do you do
so you don't need a little bit of a
tease or a little bit of it
i'm sorry so so then now you're
destroying the ability so for a guy to
quote you and flirt with you
so let's talk about andrew cuomo let's
skip a go to chris cuomo
chris cuomo not saying anything about
his brother what do you think about it
he has every right to be a good brother
that's family well i think it would be
even
uglier situation if he came out on cnn
you know
the leftist media and started defending
his brother i know my brother's a good
man
he would never do this i think he took
the high road said look it's my brother
it's probably inappropriate for me to
start you know
telling the story here and i'm gonna i'm
gonna take a pass on this one
100 integrity integrity but
it's also expected like
listen i've i think you know the
higher-ups at cnn told me not to comment
on this situation it's a
there's a you know there's moving parts
of this yeah you know like you know
ron ron reagan not ronald reagan the
atheist
the son yeah i mean you know
and or you know you got the the conway
daughter kelly johnson situation
right ugly you're saying something about
the family you're going family
i have so much respect for the fabric
of the the cuomo parents how they raise
their kids
because i sat there and i said say it's
my two boys tikkun dylan right
something like this happens listen i i
swear to god if you throw your brother
under the bus you are not going to like
what's going to happen yeah
family first you got to respect what is
going on here you do not go out there
privately guess what i want you to do go
do whatever you want to tell him
privately
chew his ass out push him around what
were you thinking
what the let's just say you can do that
privately cool
publicly family first i i respect
i don't agree politically but i respect
the decision see that's the part
with the family sat on what they have i
actually respect
what they're doing i think the question
now becomes should he get uh
uh uh you know impeach should he go
through that and you know
impeached well not should he should
cuomo resign and step away
to step down i mean that's ridiculous
well just let me give my two cents real
quick
on this cuomo situation interesting
perspective about the inside job i could
see something like that you know maybe
he's made some enemies certainly with
his rise to
start power and stardom over the last
year but
you know the nursing home thing isn't
even a they're not talking about that
for some reason right now
obviously i think that's the main story
you know and like even when we went to
your office the other day watch this
video
what are your thoughts on it i was like
the hot dog video i was like expecting
something so much worse or watch this
video where he
put his hand i was expecting oh damn
here it is here's the bomb
he's like yeah yeah have a bite of a hot
dog like because she's eating a hot dog
like
i was expecting something so much worse
something so much salacious that i was
like that's
it this is what this guy is but you know
why it's happening tell me why
why do you think it's happening why
these stories are coming out no why do
you think they're asking
why why do you think we're in the
movement of stepping down resign and
peach why do you think we're not
movement
you're back into the canceled culture
you caused it yeah you're the one that
wanted to impeach trump twice
you caused it so this one that's that's
that that would be
the republicans kind of coming after him
this is more inside though no no what
i'm saying to you is
we're officially in the era of you
should resign
you should step down you should impeach
them we're in that era it's normal now
you mean no
no no we are and i'm i'm i'm drawing a
line saying that's right
now you're canceling the will of the
people you're canceling voters
unfortunately once you do it once kind
of like what you said about aoc's
filibuster two years from now it's going
to backfire on you and that's
exactly what's happening so guess what
cuomo you said he should be impeached
hey it's backfiring on you you're now
it's coming back on you
so you're getting the taste of your own
medicine so so in 10 years ago what do
you mean resign but today
you should resign based on what you
thought trump should do
so you're getting the taste your
medicine i think a part of
a part of the uh you reap what you sow
yeah part of a part of this is
you know well there's two two quick
thoughts
number one what was acceptable 50 years
ago
100 years ago 200 years ago
is not acceptable anymore like i
remember one of the first shows i ever
watched was
archie bunker i used to have a black and
white tv in like 1989.
and she bunker would say the most
ridiculous stuff and that was like
the main tv show in america no way
archie bunker's on tv these days do you
remember archie bunker
all in the family yeah okay so that was
completely acceptable in the 70s or the
80s
zero percent chance it's acceptable now
um
the washington redskins i mean we can go
down the list here the washington
redskins
doctor's and the dr seuss but you can't
cancel the past and i was guilty of this
even on one of the first podcasts when
we were talking about they were taking
down the confederate statues
and emotionally i was like get those
pieces of [ __ ] traders out of here
cancel them all
take down the statues no relax you can't
just cancel history
you can put it in a museum though you
can still
you know have it you know in certain
sections you don't have to agree with it
you can just cancel history so and then
you have people like
extremists on the left who are trying to
cancel abraham lincoln
oh for god's sake which is like to me
the the dumbest thing on the george
washington's next he's coming up don't
worry tell me that's
freaking absurd yeah so well whose fault
is the whole cancer culture so what's
this whole cancer culture deal
how did it start who how did it start
how are we here
how is it that everybody keeps like hey
you said this you're cancelled hey you
said this you're canceled
he just brought up the two percent i
can't talk about exactly okay so
so the level of sensitivity is at the
highest
it's ever been we are so sensitive
because we're all about
feelings and we're all about how you
feeling
right oh my did we offend you do we say
something that amen and i don't know
yeah um yeah all of that it's so like
did you hear about the thing yesterday
with flag
that you can in dc you can't have a flag
above certain size to hang outside your
house and they're saying well you it's
offensive to some people so they're
making a flag side
which flag u.s flag excuse me you didn't
hear about this yesterday
go search it you're going to crack up in
america
in america and it's in court they're
talking and the people are agreeing
you can't have a certain size flat to
hang outside because it's too much
in people's face too much america too
much america well
i'm sorry but you know it started with
this woke
culture unfortunately and and look
to a certain to a certain extent
there are some merits in it like if
you're a native american
and you're looking at the washington
redskins and you're like yo i'm like
they're straight up like
okay so they're they're calling me a
[ __ ] like that's like that's like
they had a team called like the uh
washington brownskins and it was a
picture of an iranian guy you'd be like
i'm a little offended here
a little bit okay i am bone skin okay
cool but i like it
i like it too you look especially after
hawaii you were tana's head
should i leave yeah
[Laughter]
all this hot romance going on
but you can't change the past but you
can learn from it and i think canceled
culture is a very slippery slope
i think bill maher had a great point
that like everyone's cancelable these
days because everyone has a social media
profile so
everyone's you know out there so
anything you do
anything you say is potentially cancel
cancel
cancel that guy write him off cut the
show that's it yeah it's good
it's like at what point do you have just
the freedom of expression it's gonna
backfire like it's backfiring on cuomo
you have to understand if you go
through it the way some are going
through it the backfiring is going to
come
you're going to pay a price if you go
that way it's going to come you can't
just go thinking you can bully everybody
people behind closed doors sit there and
plan things that
may take 20 to 30 years for it to become
a reality
you don't want those types of people
they're giving birth to a lot of people
that are going to be thinking what
they're going to be doing 20 30 years
from now
and and and and you you're giving birth
to a lot of true believers today by
pissing them off by taking their voice
away
you don't take a voice away from
somebody it irritates them in a
different way
it's a different freedom you take away
well they're kind of doing it right now
but let's talk about brazil
brazil okay brazil oil industry shake-up
could be devastating for its economy
following the
ousting of the sea of brazil's
state-controlled oil groups
by president bolsonaro earlier
bolsonaro earlier this week experts fear
what greater interest intervention might
do to the country
following the change in leadership some
religion stocks plummeted losing 20
of their value monday around 13 billion
dollars this also had a negative effect
on brazil's currency
which decreased in value by two percent
what are your thoughts on what's going
on in brazil
so in 1964 the united states funded and
financed a coup
and that military regime uh
was around until 1985. that was it was
almost
two decades before they had an election
an elected
president uh bolsonaro
happens to have been a member of the
military regime
back then so it is a very slippery slope
in a country that has been devastated by
the virus
to try and swing the pendulum back to
another military regime and that is why
four members of the board of directors
of petrobras
stepped down in protest when he instated
a general
who knows nothing about energy as its
ceo
these are not the kind of things that
you want to read it's it's why they call
emerging economies emerging markets
emerging
because they don't do things that
developed economies would
and but brazil is a big damn economy
it's the biggest economy in latin
america and you don't want to see this
happen
at all you don't want nationalism you
don't want these types of trends to
start because they can be contagious
from one country to another we've seen
it we've seen this in the past
and again we were talking about the
economic reliance on china
so you start lining up the dominoes and
this is this
hopefully somebody in the cia is wise to
what's happening down there
because this is not the way we want for
it to go in 1964 the united states was
financing the coup who knows who's
behind
what's happening now but this is not not
a good direction
uh 64 was it jfk or was it lyndon who
funded london linda funded the coup and
kissinger came out
a few years afterwards kissinger came
out and said
we know that they were killing off
dissidents
it wasn't anything like chile where they
killed a ton of people
but there were there were many many
dissidents speaking of suppressing free
speech
bad things happen and they tortured
their own people they killed their own
people they exiled
if you ever exiled you you had that was
a good verdict
but you don't want to see these
developments so what's next if this
continues what happens to brazil who do
they become are they like the next
venezuelan
adam said yesterday that is a risk
you don't want to see that i know you
have a soft spot for south america you
lived in venezuela
you know you got a great spanish accent
um i'd love to
love to hear more spanish on the show we
have we got some colombians and
venezuelans and mexicans in the house
not that mexican so but
brazil's the powerhouse in south america
right i mean for sure not even a
question
and you know being here in south florida
we have an influx of venezuelans
yes you do bananas there's brazilians
here argent i mean argentina's
a mess i guess just give me your
economic
synopsis and what's happening in south
america how that affects us
here in america because we have our own
issues to frickin deal with and
the last part of that is how big on the
[ __ ] show level is brazil right now
like well overall economics this is this
is kind of the first shot across the bow
so the person who used to
run petrobras who was ousted was a
university of chicago educated economist
who believed in free markets
and that was kind of the direction that
south america was taking
looking at the example of venezuela and
saying we don't want to go there
so this is not something that you want
to see but at the root
is income inequality and
terrible income inequality in the
favelas it's insane in brazil
oh my gosh yeah yes and that is where a
lot of the coveted deaths
occurred so we're seeing similar
situations play out
in peru mexico and in the united states
income inequality is an economic
phenomenon that
that will come back and kill capitalism
so i i know three things about this guy
bolsonaro
uh and obviously there's we're learning
more about him i know
i know number one they called him the
brazilian trump
right uh he would refuse to wear a mask
and then he got covered
and then you see all these images of
like burning
the amazon in brazil and him
sort of not giving enough of what's
going on there so he seems
just completely narcissistic
yeah i don't i don't know what the word
is that what's your take on this guy
bolsonaro
i think that power corrupts absolutely
and we're seeing an example of that but
again you have to remember
his roots his roots were in that
military regime
gotcha that we do not want to see brazil
go back to
because you don't want to have economies
that are susceptible
to becoming future allies of china and
it all i mean i'm sorry but all roads
lead back to beijing
wow and it is it's it's an economic
matter
and you you care who butters your bread
that's it
so so is china using the playbook that
u.s has used for decades
themselves so they're they're they're
internally funding coups and they're
taking over
i mean you got that's a that's an
interesting meddling in elections you're
saying they are
they are just but they're saying hey we
learned it from you thank you you know
we learned it from you you taught us how
to do this and we think it's a great
strategy we're just going to do it
better than you because during during
the industrial revolution in the united
states we trashed our environment
in order to build out our our companies
in order to build our industrial sector
and what have they done they've trashed
their economy and they've built out
their industrial systems trash their
environment
environment sorry yes what is the
current state of china and the
environment and the smog and the smoke
and the emotions
and everything why don't we go busy i'm
not gonna go yeah why don't we go for a
week
we go me you and rudy giuliani the three
of us
why don't we go visit and take me
you mario sam paul kai that's just the
squad
mysteriously we all disappear and never
come back
what happened to entertainment i have no
idea where'd vt go
value china value chinomix ginomics
value trinomics
no that wouldn't go right but we go
visit i think it's the best thing to do
we go find out how it is
i wonder what would happen if we went i
actually did you feel safe would you
feel safe going to china right now for a
week
to macau yeah we go to macau hong kong
i'd go to hong kong not that that's
mainland china
i'd go to hong kong have you ever
watched the news lately well you know
it's it's it's it's
becoming more mainland but would you go
to macau we go one one week we stay at
the best hotel at macabre look at the
win
would you go who's funding this trip i
would find it
all right i'm in okay that's all you
needed
but would you go if i funded it would
you go i mean if you felt comfortable
people come to i'm not like
i would never go there i'm not against
china or the people of china the best
thing about the government
because when you go in your macho 23
hours 22 hours 21 hours three hours
two hours one hours border and then
we're landing and you're getting out
yeah and you look at adam's face adam's
got the mask on he's
any flight that long hey if you're if
you're watching this if you're watching
this
if you had a chance right now would you
feel safe going to china
today would you feel safe go would you
feel safe going to china today
you would kai i'd
you would be yeah but look at kai i mean
come on i'm norwegian though if i
if i went there you would be okay kai is
like primed for a kidnapping get this
little kid over here just just like
i don't know i'm not even holding this
guy ransom just get over here get in the
car guys i don't know would you guys go
into uh
to china eric would you go i think you
would go if we could i could have been
stationed there i'm not a big fan of
counter intelligence
counterintelligence threat countries so
i don't like to be followed i don't like
to go to the hotel and know that there's
cameras
china russia yeah this guy lived in
russia for four years though
so did you you lived in russia for four
years no one year
one year and there's counterintuition so
if you go
yeah so if you're talking in your room
you just have to know everybody's
listening we're getting
a fantasy we're getting sprayed with
no's no no no
no no no it's like a host offer said yes
yeah alex said yes you got to see
i wouldn't even comment volvo i mean
they're listening in your vulnerability
all middle
our friend michael says as a black man
hell no i don't know what like what that
has to do with anything
chemo yes for china i would go
uh a bunch of other people are saying uh
no here's the question for you
pbd yeah the founder of valuetainment
from iran
speaks out against china
country you're more likely to visit
sooner right you know soon next country
iran or china or iran that's a good
question
i would visit both but that's the
deflective answer
country you will set foot in first if
you're betting
betting man roll the dice
red for china black for iraq i couldn't
tell you but
i don't know probably china over iran i
don't know
because it's more likely you would
travel there like i would
i would travel to both but what's more
likely you wouldn't be
seen again in those two countries that
was the question
yeah you read my mind well not seen
again i think
you would see me again in iran but they
may keep me in iran
china you may never see me again
i would play hide and go seek and i'd
win for 60 years
you're winning you and jack ma hanging
out
winning i would have a six day
presentation so let us tell you moving
forward what you have to say about china
but can you imagine like you're in your
suite in china you're staying at a nice
hotel in china and you know you're being
recorded so you say
what a wonderful country china is don't
they just have the greatest system in
the world
i love how we were treated the food
incredible
incredible the best you know so you just
you're sitting there you're building
them up
and then you tease them you tease them
and confuse them a little bit so what
should we do with the petroleum that we
brought here you know the nuclear
and you you kind of tease them and
they're listening to you right what
should we do with this should we
let's leave it in this room i've got the
uranium in the hotel safe yeah the
uranium let's leave it here before we
leave
have you ever been to china ever no i
have not and would you ever go
uh well all four of my children take
mandarin so i've always said that i'll
go
take a mandarin oh well if you can't
beat them join them
wow they're not gonna they're not gonna
invite them in but
at least you can understand them you
won't teach your kids mandarin
my favorite first we need to make him
have kids we gotta find him a woman's
there might be a kid that's speaking
spanish somewhere in costa rica that's
all i'm saying i don't know
that they had some fun there okay that
was okay
what you're the only appropriate you're
the only person that's allowed to visit
south america
you're the only
is he southerner is he 10 that that's
where the confusion is uh
probably he would he he or she would be
about 11 years old now but
who's counting well so you were 30 30
when you're at 29
right right around 29 30 yeah yeah
bachelor parties
i just fell in love fell in love for a
week
for a day there you go okay how about
danielle you're the only person allowed
to visit south america what's going on
here
with the stripper so i'll buy you a
drink
that's when that song was bobbing which
one i'm gonna buy you
oh yeah do you know who t-pain is
i'm afraid i don't t-pain oh my you and
i both
okay so let's let's let's do tesla i
don't want i do want to hit this
tesla tesla to launch full self-driving
car
uh subscription within four months ilama
says that tesla will launch it
it's full service uh in the next three
to four months the automaker is set to
launch the option for full self-driving
package which cost ten thousand dollars
at the purchase of a new tesla vehicle
here's what you get with the package
navigate on autopilot
auto lane change auto park summon
full self driving computer traffic light
and stop light control
stop sign control tesla also plans for
the package to eventually lead to
full self driving capability but the
automaker has already missed a few
timelines on that front and even if it
achieved it the release will be
dependent on regulatory approval which
is market specific
yeah okay that package is missing the
driver
just saying
so what do you think because i know
you're you're an uber guy yeah
a tesla comes out with something like
this would you buy it is this true you
don't drive a car
i don't know no no i haven't had a car i
haven't had a car in 10 years it's
it's actually the world is a safer place
yeah adam drives sidewalks at boca raton
or safety yes
well my bicycle is pretty rad dude um
did you say two is it really though you
have one of those you have a real nice
bike or you got one of those like uh
beach cruiser i'm not i'm just taking my
time i'm you know it's good for south
beach
i'm not trying to win a marathon here
but back to tesla
wow so much fun danielle imagine if we
had some wine here
i think we do that late night one night
um
wow like this is happening like i
remember seeing
you know test drive you know have you
seen the you know the cars with the sign
on it like
the jetsons no well that too but
you would see driverless it would have a
sign on it driverless car like
you know just be careful like we're out
here and
it's happening like there's full-on
driverless cars now so like
you for instance you joked about it
earlier imagine
you buy a tesla you're pat you got zoom
calls you're doing interviews you got
you're doing dream team meetings and
you're not even having to look at the
road
this is pretty impressive stuff this is
like where we're at right now in
in life right now in 2021 is that you
just get behind a wheel of a tesla and
get to where you're going if there was a
full-on self-driving car that all you do
is sit
put the address it goes to it would you
buy it
i i mean or would you still stick to
uber like would you buy it would you buy
a self-driving car you don't do the
driving it's purely automatic the the
thing with me is why i didn't have a car
was because i lived in downtown miami
and
to get anywhere i was going it's all
within a two minute five dollar uber
yeah and half the time quite frankly i
was going to south beach and
partying and drinking and the last thing
i needed to be doing was having a car
so if you don't and i've said this a
million times if you don't have a car
payment and if you're not paying for
insurance and you're not paying for gas
and maintenance and flat tire and
somebody hits your rear view mirror and
you're driving a curve and next thing
you know even nailing it like you can
save a lot of money
and i've saved a lot of money not having
a essentially a 10
000 expense for 10 years putting that
into the market who knows what's
happened in the market like
i've gone on on that so for me it's not
about oh i don't want to actually
drive it's the it's the financial
component but
for someone like you who it's
has kids has a family it has to drive
around you're moving you're grooving
and you're doing 10 different things all
at once i don't see a reason why you
would not consider this
i would i think if there's a
self-driving car that takes me anywhere
the challenge is also i like driving
though i
enjoy driving that's crazy
let me tell you what happened the other
day the other day i missed having a
stick
shift like i missed driving stick shift
like our friend paul
oh i mean you know it's is your stick
shifter no
what which car is stick shift the
challenger no it's not yeah yeah
is that a is that an option like you
have an option to pick up stick shift
no it's full manual it's 100 percent
manual 100
oh let me tell you not have the option
to drive it like that does nothing for
me
it's like so you want to do more work
just to get where you're going i need to
like be reversing and neutral
i like driving okay i like speed but i
think for business i would absolutely
buy one if there's a self-driving car
luxury say you have a nice escalade
luxury self-driving car that's going to
take me
what have i told you that you need a
million times
a drive a personal driver yeah straight
now you have it built in and you don't
got to pay the person well it's not
fully it's not fully fully what's it
missing
it's if it's a fully self-driving
capability
i am all in one of my cars will be a
self-driving uh
car yeah once the technology is proven
i'm all over it
i am but i'm not going to be the guinea
pig okay so you're waiting
yeah you're kind of like uh how no
you're going to be the guinea pig with
the vacuum
you're okay so you would be okay to just
get into a machine and it takes you
place and you're not driving
absolutely not a fan no no i mean i i
would want the option still to drive but
yeah
75 percent of time i don't want to drive
eric youtube
i don't like driving no sam do you like
driving
no more than an hour sam loves minutes
kai what do you think
so i think there's two components
obviously initially if
if all the cars are digital and driving
by themselves
i feel a lot safer if you have people
like sam driving and your car is
peacefully driving
uh self-driving then that could be an
issue there
i'm good then yeah
and that is with with cars and
think of how you would change driving if
you don't have to change
you if you don't have to drive there say
you have like a desk in the back or you
can do something
productive and still show up where you
want to go
then you don't have the component of
travel time because that can then be
incorporated into
doing whatever you're doing anyways so
essentially how we move around would
completely change in that case because
now a four hour drive
is you watching a movie for four hours
and
you get up you get out of the car and
you're somewhere else or you've got
wi-fi and you're working
exactly you've got your laptop going in
my opinion your your
um little narrative there about like i
love driving is gonna be
you know a few decades from now the
equivalent of someone saying
oh i just love horseback riding i love
it i got a horse i love it it's my
favorite
like i think that's where we're going
like there's eventually so far there's
going to be every car is going to be
driving like
it's going to limit accidents uh it will
mitigate it will mitigate traffic
all that everyone's going to be on the
same page and you can just do what you
want to do okay
that driver who's driving slow in the
fast lane that won't exist
that's every day to work florida people
i don't understand
slower drivers why are semi's driving in
the far
left lane like i don't get it buddy
you're in the wild west here you're in
florida no no by the way
honestly no joke terrible drivers i
don't know what they're doing like
why are there's driving safety in the
far left lane there's
no you know who i put out the top
california texas or that uh or
or uh florida atlanta is bad who are the
best drivers
best drivers new york california best
drivers california texas or florida who
are the best drivers
calvin texas i say california really
yeah hands down florida's the worst
hands down oh we got eight-year-olds we
got people who just showed up in this
country like out of nowhere and
they don't know what's going on you got
tourists you got europeans you're
driving
with people that show up out of another
country i like i liked your time your
tan browns
can you look great oh i did great on you
but here's the question
for you pat because i know we're going
to wrap up here seriously
how many tickets accidents incidents
have you been in the last handful of
years and how many cops say oh mr bet
david good to see you again how often
does that happen
that's a lot okay that's a lot okay so
imagine if that was zero
but i get a chance to meet a cop and we
talked about that
relationship i'm good how are you doing
it's called networking yeah patrick's
future in politics
yes okay if i'm driving how do you spin
something like that yeah i'm good i got
to meet a great i like having a neutral
relationship with cops i don't want to
talk to you you don't need to talk to me
i'm not going to wait on you you need to
have a job neutral relationship with a
woman who can procreate i have a lot of
me over
non-mutual relationships he caught me
racing
in a z06 and i was racing a motorcycle
oops okay yeah
and by the way jennifer's in my car so
i'm on the left he's over here
okay the bike and i said you want to go
he said let's go and i'm in victorville
out of all the places so i'm thinking no
cops i'm gonna be safe
so he says ready he says let's go we go
takes off
i'm going 135 miles an hour cop pulls me
over
i'm like get that and this is like
reckless driving at the highest level
you're going to believe jennifer's i
told you
i told you but and so cop
comes up i said he says do you know why
i pulled you over i said yeah cause i
beat you you couldn't judge it
he starts cracking up he starts laughing
i said
i said i beat you you couldn't get the
only reason you called me is because of
red light
so what the hell is the matter with you
it says you realize that's reckless
traffic i said listen can you let me go
i don't do this often he says based on
your record you do i said yeah
exactly he says you know what forget
about it you're craziest guy i've met go
just let you go you didn't give me
tickets what's it say
officer jones wherever you are shout out
to you and victor world you're amazing
now i gotta
tell you jones come out to florida
z06 going up against the bike guess what
the bike did
destroyed the z06 okay it's a bike
that's a jigsaw
destroyed the zoc destroyed
the z06 you want to know where i'm at
with this i have zero clue what a z06 is
a jigsaw
nothing yeah my uber would have my uber
would have become in last place okay
do you know can i ask you a question yes
ma'am women like men who understand cars
okay so start start studying that's true
but he knows he knows bicycles
oh god that's hot
get out my handlebars david who needs
wine when you've got bicycles i hope you
got a big
trunk i'm gonna stick my bike in it but
what
did you just say that out loud that's a
40 year old virgin reference
uh the movie by the way so you and cuomo
wouldn't be too far off if you were his
age that's my guy
you may as well call you adam cuomo you
know
let's not start that let's just stick
with the soybeans okay here's a trivia
question for you i'm with pat
we're we show up la land lax boom
we get a car it's waiting there for this
guy like
the prince just arrived we show up
bentley's sitting there me
you and tico boom we're hanging all
right
i'm in he's like adam welcome to my
world right you know i'm like all right
i'm in l.a
i'm on the 405. brand new maybe a couple
hundred miles on this bench please
four hundred thousand dollars new best
sick patch
danny majeed thank you danny thank you
danny pat says let's
let's test this bad boy out how fast
this is the 405 is that the 405 this is
the
freeway but it's covered 405. okay
whatever that means
that means that there's not a lot of
charges okay there was traffic galore
okay go ahead tell your story i don't
want to mess this up tell you guys
what's your point pat starts driving
pushes the bentley
how fast but wait i asked you a question
first he goes what's the fastest you've
ever
i said what's the fastest you've ever
been in a car yeah that's courtesy
yeah i give you the courtesy yeah and
then you said what i'm like maybe 105
maybe i don't know 110.
i said how about we make history
together then i asked the question he
said sure
so you gave permission for us to make
history together and then what happened
yeah yeah yeah he
i there was consent there i was like
cuomo that's what i'm going with
how many times have you said that to a
woman let's make history
well played sir i played how fast
danielle
do you think mr bet david took the belly
on the 405.
a buck 40. a buck 40. you took the under
uh can i reveal it you wanna just so you
know for all the officers that are
listening to this this is pure
speculation
he's assuming this is where we went but
go ahead tell him what you saw he hit
150 155 i was close
and that wasn't enough for him danielle
so he said let's do it again the remix
we hit 165
165 miles per hour what did it feel like
it felt like we were driving seven i
can't
wait it felt like we were going 70.
we were passing cars in the freeway as
if you're going 100 miles an hour and
they're parked
165 miles per hour so now you know
when i say passed maybe you need a
driver pat maybe you need a
you need you need to call our good
friend friend of the show elon musk
and maybe you can work out a deal with a
driverless car and what do i drive today
i drive a
shelby big ass shelby truck that i go
around if i hit curbs and
you feel nothing but your your rear view
mirror
your side view mirror somebody hit it i
wasn't in the car somebody hit it and
ran off i chased them down but
when somebody hit your tire the guy hits
my tire yeah do you remember the picture
that car what happened that they hit my
tire on a turn
they accidentally hit my their entire
side was trashed
and i'm looking at it i'm like what the
hell happened to the car nothing just
scratches on the tire
the shelby truck destroyed the car you
know it's crazy do you know what a
shelby is
yes because women like uh guys who know
about cars i don't know if you know
about that i heard i heard a thing or
two
we go to we go to um and then you got
the the suv
and then you messed up the tires i
bought the escalade first time i drive
it i tore the tire
first time first down yeah ten miles
past the car
well first of all here when you drive
it's very if you think about it when
you're driving trucks it's not a good
idea to drive drugs every time i come up
i'm like you know what
i'm every time i'm hitting the side but
can can we avoid talking about my
my uh driving abilities and speed limits
does seem to be a bit funny i'm gonna
i'm gonna make a point here about your
shelby there's a point
there's a point hit it got it hit it
let's see
daniel what are you talking about i
drive a big ass escalade
big ass escalator it's the right one to
drive b-a-e
um we go to we go to lunch and this is
in
miami and we we leave the it's raining
we dropped the cars off uh oh no i'm
sorry pat says
uh we dropped the kids off i said all
right let me let me go deal with the
valet i'm gonna jump out we're draining
or ever go to the restaurant
the valet guy i don't know nothing about
cars it's like dude
shelby what's up i'm like yeah all right
cool buddy take the keys of the truck
we come back out he goes i gotta tell
you this is the valet guy he goes i
drive lamborghinis i drive
ferraris but the shelby my number one
vehicle i was like
really the truck but this shelby i guess
is a big deal
man even when he knows his engine we
even went into
uh prestige auto looking at ridiculous
cars down in miami
and the guy was super impressed with
this paganis and bugatti's
you were looking at real cars yes cars
cars cars but the shelby was like the
tactical only make 500 of them they
don't make that many of them so you know
they have cars for dummies it's like a
whole book you can read yeah and you can
procreate right
so creation goes
through yes my question to you danielle
is
he's going to make history is is
today's tied is the ability to have a
car payment is that what's going on
no no no no you've got to you've got
money you have this is not much
here's your future line i buy my car's
cash
okay you could i could do that you could
if you were to buy one would you or
would you still do a range rover deal or
maybe that e3
e500 you saw like an e-class i did like
a nice
mercedes class mercedes that could be
dope go for the 50 grand
what v12 yeah go for it i don't see you
as a lexus guy
don't do lexus that's for you no you
know what's crazy is i actually bought
my ex alexis that's the only car the
rhymes actually yeah
i feel like i'm not testing that guy you
think adam's a tesla kind of guy
by the way by the way i actually see him
as yeah yeah it's got style
it's got you know what else i really see
him in no joke
no joke i see him in a nice 911.
oh yeah i see him in a night i think
it's a 911. oh my gosh
of course focus
skip today's podcast okay what's a 911
listen
okay you want to talk about getting laid
let me tell you something
he's going to make history he's going to
make history he has everything
i would live in south when i would be
where in miami this weekend yeah so i
live in south beach
i had a sick apartment okay in the
marquee
okay and um
here it is a loft amazing like
my friend called it a abajo panty party
a
abajo panty like a penny dropper
apartment incredible
so you go out in south beach you meet
girls whatever you take an uber back to
your place they don't give two shits
about what kind of call you drive
they're in your apartment it's great
that's my point like you never have to
like bro i'm just telling you
times
uh with how well of a prospector you are
we've all witnessed it you know how how
well you are
this approach is so great this is adam
he goes to place hey ladies i have some
friends here how are you good
let me introduce you yeah basic script
he's got he just goes
from my friends here yeah except for
paul
i have not been the recipient of any of
adam's goodwill
i've taken pulitz bombs
oh my god i tried to help paul out he's
like you can't help the
unhelpable you cannot i tell you the one
story i told about paul
when i just moved to dallas we're going
to a bar and
i have no clue where we're going so who
do i want to ask any nice
local lady hey ladies like are we on the
right direction to the good part of town
like
they're like yeah yeah go that with this
bars thank you thank you cuckoo cool
after one or two girls that we speak to
paul's like i have the gps right here
why don't you keep asking all these
girls it was literally like five feet
like i just naturally couldn't deal with
that we're not morons
why do you keep asking these pretty
girls for directions i have the gps
like what are you doing bro i don't like
looking clueless though you know
play dumb girls like intelligent people
too
yeah that's working out well for you
guys yeah it does i do fine
i do just fine shout out to my ladies
out there
[Laughter]
we're we're thinking about it drives hey
here you don't drive a car and he drives
a stick shifter
yeah so he's we couldn't be further
apart right further apart
zero cars stick shifts put in a lot of
forward but technically speaking he
knows how to drive
yeah that's true so do you honestly do
now know what a 911 is i think it's a
porsche
would would you it is a porsche yeah i'm
not a porsche guy at all
too small have you sat in one have i
ever been on a porsche yeah have you
driven one
no how did we get here by the way this
whole
i think i think you would just go to sit
in one one time all right just go sit on
one
you know what why don't you rent a
porsche for a day it's like 500 bucks
400 bucks
just just to drive a porsche just to get
a feel on what it feels like i see you
in a porsche
expense it to valuetainment yeah done
don't i just don't see
i just don't see like by the way last
thing here
barack obama bruce springsteen start a
podcast yes together
okay a president and a rock star start a
podcast it's going to be called
renegades born in the usa
it's part of a multi-year partnership
with spotify brock and michelle obama's
production company higher ground
spotify's deal with higher ground
announced june in june of 2019 was one
that's earlier big bets in a podcast
industry earlier the same year spotify
acquired
podcast studio gimlet okay got it
so how do you think this is going to go
with these guys start a podcast together
by the way somebody said adam is
officially a 9-4 i just want you to know
that
adam also just got five dollars for a
porsche
more for the rental just one day that's
right we only need 4.95 for the rental
valuetainers will support it but
bruce springsteen i'm gonna start a
gofundme for adam can i get can i get
from a
8.5 to an eight-pointer to a potential
9.2 million
you pull up with a porsche you you're
getting close to a dime absolutely wow
this is what's happening
yes so it's an impression by the way yes
so now
barack obama bruce springsteen how good
is it going to do okay number one that's
potentially going to be the number one
podcast on the planet
other than ours okay clearly especially
when we talk about
uh the you know the cars 911 you have
you have
um i can't think there's two parts of
this story here and then i'm going to
turn it over to the lovely danielle
dimartino booth
renegades born in the usa you don't
think that's like a
birther joke like come on trump born in
the usa
two-term president really don't think
they're going there well i think that's
exactly where they're going number one
bruce springsteen's greatest hit is
arguably born in the usa
and born in the usa springsteen one time
trump was playing it he said i don't
want you to play that
exactly there's a shot here at trump by
the way there's a hundred percent of
shot here at trump
that's what i'm saying yeah absolutely
that's exactly what i'm saying trump
obviously rose to power
through birth on the birtherism thing
born in the usa renegades so
i think he's going right at trump and
don't don't think
that obviously we talked about governors
being competitive and
to become president you need to be
competitive i'm sure presidents
are the most competitive and if trump
and obama are ever in a room together
you know obama's going to be like
two terms baby two terms born in the usa
fist bump i'm out dropped the mic you've
seen him drop a mocking mic i'm just
think
yeah that's where he's at with that do
you think he's gonna do good
oh gosh i mean who doesn't love bruce
springsteen
i'm sorry is somebody else involved this
guy named
barack hussein obama oh sorry yes i'm
i'm sure he'll be a nice
accoutrement for he's the he's the side
dish to bruce
briggs sings main dish but who's gonna
have better stories
i think obama's the i mean he's gonna i
think obama you take off your politics
hat
and you know maybe he inhales once or
twice in his life i don't know
you know i'm speculating once or twice
that's what i'm saying like these days
not once or twice
lets his hair down maybe puts a little
afro sheen in that thing i think he
could have a
great set of stories i think it could be
really fun
so so then the question becomes the
following what okay i'm going to throw
something out there for you
he had me at afrosh wait but but hear me
out so
so by the way coming to america two is
coming out this weekend speaking of soul
glow in africa
so so renegades born in the usa obama
and springsteen yes
say a year from now another podcast gets
started yeah trump and kid rock
who wins wow that would actually be
honest
or obama and you know what i'd love to
see
that i would love trump and kid rock or
somebody like that to start a podcast
kid rock is pretty loud as well so if
they started it together
and they have it to see how competitive
these two podcasts are awesome
and eminem hates uh trump but but rock i
think but if kid rock
and trump did it obama and bruce do it
who wins
actually who wins what do you think i
actually think trump would win
you think trump would win i think listen
as much as i'm not a fan of trump
people are tuning in to this what that
monster has more than obama
yes okay yeah wow i'd agree with you but
there's one reason why
i think trump would say more kind of
outlandish things which is what you
often want from the podcast
howard stern said it and said it best
people that love howard stern listen for
an hour
why because they want to hear what he
says next people that hate howard stern
listen for an hour and a half why
because they want to hear what he has to
say next
you know you said it earlier in the show
media ratings are down
because trump's not around people want
to hear what he has to say next it's
outlandish it's ridiculous it's divisive
it's racist whatever you want to call it
if it bleeds it leads they want to hear
what it has to say let me
say do you think there's any chance he
starts a podcast
do you think there's kai turn off your
mic do you think there's any chance he
starts a podcast i think with trump
there's a chance for anything
okay an insurrection a podcast who knows
it's all yeah
it's all in the cards okay so that is
the end of today's podcast
when is our next ones uh next one gang
when is it is next next tuesday tuesday
okay so next tuesday we're back uh on
the podcast here danielle
it's been a pleasure having you great to
be here we are looking forward to the
next time i know you got some things
you're doing here the next couple days
adam's got an interview that's going to
be coming out with danielle yes
that should come out on the next week so
stay tuned for that but everybody that
tuned in if you enjoyed it
smash that subscribe button and have a
wonderful rest of your day
and weekend take care everybody
you